mark what do you think makes you
different than the thousands of other
screenwriters who came to la
during your time here what do you think
made it different for you well i think i
was very very lucky
in the fact that
i was enthusiastic about science fiction
from when i was a small boy and science
fiction unlike a lot of other genres the
fans became the writers and so they had
a sense of wanting to pay it forward so
when i noticed that the same writers
were writing for star trek and outer
limits and twilight zone as we're
writing the short stories and books that
i was reading and the novels ray
bradbury harlan ellis and theodore
sturgeon richard matheson
etc i could then go to science fiction
conventions when i was a teenager and i
sought these wonderful people out and
they became mentors and friends that
that helped enormously and uh
and also i just had such a passion
for writing i had such a i i had a sense
of calling from a very early age and i
understood
that
because of rod sterling because of so
many of these writers that i admired
that you could aim high you didn't have
to blend in you just had to be
clear
what you were
sharing with the world
and ray bradbury was a mentor of mine
for over 10 years i'd go over to his
house once a month for over 10 years
toward the end of his life and ray
always used to say look inward don't
look out for your material look inward
and that doesn't mean that you can't
write about things that are different
from your life it just means that you
find your passions
and the your true self
inward and then you put that out to the
world and uh
and so i i had extremely good teachers
in that way because uh i think some
writers out of fear feel that they have
to imitate others or write down to their
audience i've never felt that i'm the
same as my audience and
if i come across an idea or a story or
characters or whatever that excites me
um
usually my audience will be excited too
by what i'm doing and uh
i trust my audience i don't i they're
they're
i feel i'm with my family when uh when
i'm talking to
all the weirdos
weirdos are good things yeah i like
weirdos yeah yeah yeah
how did you know that you could actually
get something made i mean there's a lot
of people who love a certain genre but
they dabble in it or they're on the sort
of the outside the outer limits so to
speak how did you know though that you
could get something made and eventually
be successful at it well i didn't i
didn't have a
in terms of knowing that i would be
successful i didn't know that it was uh
there are basically two people who are
responsible for my career more than
anyone which is my wife elaine who i met
when i was 20. we got married when i was
21 now we've been together 45 years and
married 44 and we write and produce and
direct together and
my friend michael reeves who was writing
for television and brought me into
animation when i was uh like 22 23 years
old
so
i started by knowing
by the time i got out of art school my
degrees in painting sculpture and
graphic arts from ucla and because i
always knew i was going to be an artist
or a writer but by the time i went
through college and then went to the
clarion writers workshop
and sold my first short story i knew i
was going to be a writer and
so i thought well how do you learn how
to be a writer in television
and there was really no there was no
graduate school in that at the time
we're talking the late 70s and
so i thought well i'll write a book
about one of the greatest television
shows ever made
to learn how to make great television
and so that's why what gave me the idea
to do the twilight zone companion it was
two years after rod serling's death and
had rod not died prematurely terribly
sadly at age 50.
i wouldn't have embarked upon that book
because if anyone should have written a
book about the twilight zone it would
have been rod but since he wasn't with
us anymore i thought well let me follow
this and see where it leads now elaine
was invaluable because i started writing
the book interviewing over 100 people
who had worked on the show and it
started getting rejected when i started
submitting it it was rejected by 25
publishers over a two year period and
probably if i would if i'd been left to
my own
devices i would have probably quit and
elaine said no no just keep going and
but we also looked at what wasn't
working which was the agent i had
wasn't the right agent she wasn't
uh she wasn't seeing opportunity to
close the deal and so we i switched
agents to someone who was young and
hungry and she sold it almost
immediately to one of the publishers who
already rejected it but a different
editor who had grown up with the
twilight zone and understood why people
would want to read about that
and and the other thing i think that was
responsible for my success was
sometimes people are so dogged about
this is all i'll do
like i mean you know elaine and i have
mentored a lot of people and one person
they said well i'm i want to act in a
steven spielberg movie and we said well
you know there's a lot of other things
being cast you could you could try for
other things no no steven's it's got to
be stephen spielberg and so and we said
you know well he might only do one movie
every few years and and it might not
have a role that's right for you you're
limiting your possibilities so i knew i
wanted to be in television and i knew
that i wanted to be writing for shows
like star trek but when my friend
michael reeves was writing animation and
he said would you like to come in and
collaborate with me
i saw that as that got me into
television and then i could write spec
live action features and so forth and
that moved me then into live action tv
shows but that's how i ended up writing
for smurfs and he-man and super friends
and and all those shows and
but i always brought my a-game to
everything i did so i wasn't writing
down at all someone once asked me when i
was writing for
animation they said do you write for the
child in the audience and i said no i
write for the child and myself and so i
would go to that place
that would be delighted by the jokes or
by the stories
and then just write as truthfully as i
possibly could and uh
and that worked and uh so i've i'm very
proud of the work i did in animation as
well as the work i've done in live
action
i am here to provide a service and if i
can open a door for someone where they
understand that it's not
as hard as people make it sound you know
that's the trick of it you know it's
like that's why i wrote green lighting
yourself so people would
know that they could
be the engine
that drives their career they don't have
to
give up power they don't have to wait
for the studios and the networks or the
publishing companies even to see their
value because thanks to the internet
thanks the fact we all have cameras in
our pockets thanks to the fact we can
edit
on
on a mac or a pc
there's no reason not to just
make the thing you want to make give it
all of your heart and soul
and put it out to the world that's your
audience and that's how you build a body
of work you don't have to wait there's
no reason to can you succeed in
hollywood if you're not a workaholic yes
you can succeed in hollywood if you're
not a workaholic but you do have to have
a work ethic
and it's interesting in green lighting
yourself in the new book i talk about
having a life
and i deliberately put it after the
chapter on building from success
and recovering from failure and i
pointed i pointed out in the book that
whether you're succeeding or whether
you're failing it's important to have a
life separate from that because the
separate having people who love you
family friends travel doing things
separate from the work
it gives you a breadth of experience but
it also gives you a life it gives you
something
that grounds you
because you're not just someone running
after the brass ring and
so actually i know writers who have a
very balanced life between family
and the work
and i think that's that's a good idea i
don't think one should work all the time
because you run out of
uh things to draw upon creatively but
you also run out of
i mean you just go crazy
the isolation hollywood can drive people
crazy simply because they get so
materialistic they get so
success-oriented driven
that they forget why they got involved
in the first place you know i've known
people who've wanted to become who
wanted to become writers because they
wanted to get rich and i've never seen
it work
maybe someone has succeeded that but the
people that i've seen succeed are the
ones who just love
the work and they love what they're
creating and they are just
so grateful for the opportunity and uh
you know it's just there's something
like for instance i just came from a
studio that i have that's filled with
uh spaceship sets
and uh and you know we we're building an
alien spaceship we're building this
hospital in on a state space station
and to be just and we're building eight
foot tall creatures and just to be in
that world and be able to share that
world with with everyone is um
is great but elaine and i try and stop
working
in the early evening we work at least
five days a week and sometimes we'll
work weekends but we try not to but we
um
we'll work and then the evening for an
hour or two we'll just relax and watch a
movie or a tv show or something or go
for a walk or you know we and we have
own dogs and dogs force you to like get
off the sofa stop typing you know go
take them for a walk and and that
helps let the air in a bit
uh you can't i don't think you can be
successful if you don't have a work
ethic and also i think you have to stand
by your word the more you stand by your
your word the more you have a work ethic
the more you have
um at least craft if not i don't use the
word talent much because i've seen a lot
of people who had talent who got nowhere
whereas if you have passion
and craft and a work ethic and
and you
um
i mean you know the reason people
support me in so many ways is because
if i say i'm going to do something i do
it and it doesn't matter if it's easier
if it's hard if it's hard then it's hard
it's i'm not going to stop i'm not going
to
turn back i have i have work to do you
know i get on with it
and my mantra to myself um when things
are difficult is uh you know i'm made of
iron and nothing will stop me
and there are times for instance when i
did the star trek episode with george
takei it was a very grueling shoot
and uh and i said i'm made of iron and
nothing will stop me and i had to use
that but we got to the finish line and
that got nominated for the hugo and the
nebula and i'm
very very proud of that episode still
and that was for christina moses's first
tv role we cast her out of the blue and
she's now starring on a million little
things on abc so we saw what her
amazing talent was
right from the beginning
well you talked about talent and talent
is very long in this in this town but
but what if someone's sort of the
pendulum swings more toward a hedonistic
personality type
well i try not to hang out with [ __ ]
they're gonna be a really nice hedonist
they know but i mean i think
you have to treat your
body
like a car that you might own
and you want to take care of it you want
to make sure that you aren't
burning the candle at both ends you know
so many people burn out
and
you know drugs alcohol
you know self-destructive behaviors
gambling all that
i it's just not sustainable in the long
run because
it's just too hard on on your mind and
your body you know it's uh
you know i i i gravitate toward people
who have a family life most of the
people i work with are married they have
many of them have kids um i want someone
who's stable i don't want someone where
i don't know if they're going to show up
and uh so i i can make the choice
of who i work with and i've been very
lucky in terms of the actors i've worked
with even when i was at the studios
and the networks
i never had a crazy person
i always had people who were there to do
the job and they appreciated the fact
that i was really putting putting
everything i could on the page and they
would get these scripts they would love
what i was writing because it gave them
something to act some emotional through
line and
and you know so quality work
gets you quality actors get you quality
composers it get there's a ripple effect
if you're if you're doing your your best
work but you can't be thinking about oh
i've got this party to go to i've got
this no it's um
i mean that doesn't mean you can't have
fun you can't go on vacation you can't
go water skiing or whatever you know and
uh but
but at the end of the day you have to be
reliable and that means you have to like
look ahead you cannot be such an impulse
monster
that
you know it's monday and you don't know
where you're supposed to be you know so
can't wander the streets but you know so
uh so that's yeah but of course in you
know in the new book i talk about if you
if you have thrown together with someone
like that here's how you can deal with
it because i had a friend who was an
actress and she was cast on tv show huge
hit show and the um
the the star of the show is drinking all
day and being very very abusive to
people and
very insulting and she just but she
recognized to not engage to do her work
she was there to do her work and she did
it and ironically at the end of the day
the actor came up and said you were
great
and so she had succeeded i think often
what we have to do is have our eye on
the ball in terms of what we are there
to accomplish
it's not about winning every single
battle it's not about
going toe to toe with everyone it's not
an alpha dog contest
it's about what am i trying to
accomplish
and so if you say okay well
i'm here to
write a great script and turn it into a
great tv show or i'm here to give a
great performance whatever it is you
have to be clear on it but obviously the
more that you take power
the less you're going to be
frustrated by other people who are not
there for the same purpose so that's why
i have my own studio now that's why i
raise money the way i do because
um
you know it's fun to be
in charge because then they then there's
no one around to i mean if anyone's
gonna wreck it it'll be me but then
that's my fault you know it's like a
failing of whatever but um
but it's so it's so cool to work with
great people and create work that that
has meaning you know i just
i couldn't be happier
is it possible for writers starting out
today to have the same type of tv
writing career that you had
in terms of writers nowadays having the
same kind of career i had uh no they
could they can't really because
television has changed so
so much well when i uh started out i i
started writing in the late 70s and
still going strong today i've been very
lucky um
back then most shows
had freelance slots so in other words
for instance when i was a producer on
sliders we had a 22 episode order for
that season and 11 of those would be
freelance slots so every day we were
taking pitches from writers and we knew
we'd have to buy 11 scripts now we might
rewrite those extensively because we
knew the show day in and day out in a
way that the freelancers wouldn't
necessarily but that might be that first
that person's first sale it might get
them into the industry it gave so many
people chances to
get their foot in the door get a start
and and i actually ended up writing for
so many different shows because
sometimes i'd be on staff
um
but other times i'd just be a freelancer
coming in and pitching
and so it allowed me also to write for a
number of different shows much more so
than if i was on staff because you know
usually you're
exclusive to that show or you might be
able to write a feature when you're on
hiatus but
but on any given year any given day
i would be multitasking i got very very
good at multitasking
so i might be well like for instance
when i was a producer on sliders i was
writing my own scripts helping with
every phase of the writing on everyone
else's scripts and um but i was also i
sold to deep space nine that year and
far beyond the stars i had sold a
trilogy to harper collins so i was uh
starting to write the first novel with
barbara hamblin outlining the second one
with maya bonhoeff and i'd also been
hired to write all the outlines for
anamorphs and lay out that show and
write several scripts for that show
so
uh friends so i would get into my office
at um universal at six in the morning
write an entire outline for anamorphs
and then by ten i'd be done with that
i'd have faxed it to uh new york and
then the sliders guys would come in and
i'd do my sliders job all day and then
on the weekend i might be working on on
the novel so uh we're on the outline for
the deep space nine episodes so it was
uh
it was a great way to work because you
know how to to to um go from one thing
to another to another without uh losing
quality that's that's the hugely
important thing you don't you don't ever
want to be
just
providing fodder you don't you don't
want to just be writing
my friend frank spotless who created a
man in the high castle and ran the
x-files uh he says uh good enough is
never good enough and i i agree with
that 100 percent he also says you should
every time you should aim for the
bleachers because you might at least get
a single you know and it's and and i
share that view which is give it your
best i mean you should just
everything you've got should go into
everything you do
and and if it's not good enough work
work harder you know but and sometimes
you're not going to write the great
american novel or the great american
screenplay you know one of my friends
who's uh you know high on calls me quite
often and he said well you know that
episode of whatever show was forever
night or whatever the uh that show that
was on last week wasn't up to your
normal standard why was that and i said
well you know you know how like when
you're in school and sometimes you
really try your best but you get a b on
a test or a c plus or whatever it's sort
of like that you know you just you know
it just didn't come together and but
that but it wasn't for lack of trying
you know and so uh
but that's part of it and um and all but
but again but in terms of possibilities
for the writers now they're much greater
for instance when i started there were
three networks and pbs and so they had
and they were 24 7 stations they weren't
uh you couldn't watch a show when you
wanted to there was no home video
and uh so
there were only a certain number of
shows they could make just because of
the hours in a day
so it limited how many writers could get
work and it limited
the
what kind of work you could get because
if the show wasn't
approved by the network you couldn't
there's nothing you could do and if you
wanted to write something and shoot it
on your own it would cost millions of
dollars minimally
and and that was very very difficult to
raise that money now
uh there's over 500 scripted comedy and
drama series on the air
on all the networks and vod platforms
and and so there's an enormous amount
more
slots for writers additionally uh even
though there isn't freelance per se
there still is freelance in animation
but not in live action uh by and large
but also people can make their own web
series they can make their own podcasts
there's so many ways to get a following
to get an audience and um
and and i i say to everyone i wouldn't
go back to any other uh period in my
life i'm i'm happiest of all now because
i have such
i have such great autonomy uh my
audience has given me over two and a
half million dollars uh to open my own
studio and make space command and uh
and now i'm raising even more money it
turned out i had a knack and so i don't
have to ask permission from anyone i
just come up with an idea i write it i
cast it i shoot it i put it out to my my
audience around the world and
that doesn't mean that the studios and
networks and vod platforms can't be my
partners they can
but they aren't the deciding factor of
what i do in terms of what i make i'm in
terms of creatively and uh and that's a
pure joy
so going back to the 70s and then being
a freelancer yeah
completely different as to
the the tone of your day what you're
working on was it well it wasn't so much
different that's what i'm working on
because i was always working on shows
that i had a passion for so whether it
was sliders or even friday the 13th the
series which is story edited uh i would
always find the
core of it the emotional core that would
uh resonate with me
it always had to be something that i
could queue into otherwise i wouldn't
write it but and i always worked with
people who i liked and who liked me
and i was very lucky in that when this
and the studio executives and network
executives we dealt with fortunately uh
were
very supportive and very smart
and so i didn't find them intrusive
there are the other kind of executives
and and you want to try and avoid those
in in green lighting yourself i have a
section on working with stupid people
and my first piece of advice is if you
can avoid it
avoid it
but if you have to work with someone
who's in the food chain they might be
above you in the food chain here's how
you can do it and not have the work be
ruined and not have um and not be fired
and so i go into some
experiences from my career where i'm
able to walk people through that and um
but again it's
it wasn't so much
um content that was different it was
simply
it's almost like there's a difference
between performing a play if you're an
actor to an audience versus auditioning
because auditioning you need someone to
approve you in order to do your work
creatively whereas when you're in a play
performing for the audience that's the
direct relationship so the more that i
can be in the direct relationship
creatively
between the conversations between me and
the world me and my audience the better
and and really what started me on this
journey of opening my own studio and
doing crowdfunding and selling
investment shares in space command and
so forth was simply that
so many of my friends who were the
greatest writers in television had
written projects that were great and
should have become hit series and the
network or the studio cut them off at
script or cut them off at pilot the
audience never saw those great shows i
thought you know in in books once a
novelist is relatively successful then
he can create a body of work like
stephen king for instance or
name any writer that you love and and so
they have an authorial voice and a
shape to their career that follows their
enthusiasms and what they want to talk
about at any given time but that's not
true with television writers with
television writers for the most part
they are constantly stymied from doing
their the projects they're most
enthusiastic about or the projects that
might even be their best work because um
the studio and the networks have
different objectives which are primarily
financial objectives
and i'm and again they have a right to
do that if they're writing the checks
but now that we can go directly to our
audience and raise money that way the
fact that we can
now shoot for so much less because uh
digital is so much less expensive um we
can we can
change the rules to into our favor
and uh you know it used to be when when
young people would like young directors
or writers would say well i'm they're
not letting me get have my dream and i
would say well who's not letting you
have your dream they say well the
networks are the studios or whatever and
back when it cost millions of dollars to
make a movie you'd say okay well then
that makes sense they are being stymied
but now since you know they have a
camera in their pocket i don't i don't
accept that excuse anymore someone says
they're not letting me have my dream
i'll say you are um
you're using an excuse to avoid doing
the work
because the work is get a camera get
some people together get the best best
actors you can find make it happen one
way or another make it happen and
a great minute is better than a mediocre
two hours of material but if people love
it
you'll start to build your audience that
starts to build a career
how did fear of success almost ruin your
screenwriting career and when you hear
that from these these other writers yes
do you hear fear of success in their
voice or it's
it's asking for permission i think
there's always a counterweight between
fear of success and fear of failure uh
in everyone's heart in one way or
another in different measures uh one is
always afraid of exposure one is always
afraid of
screwing it up you know and
and ultimately you have to be willing
to
face that and get past it and get over
it and get around it
your job is to get your work done your
creative work and with all of my mentors
whether it's rod sterling or ray
bradbury or guillermo del toro with whom
i wrote a book not long ago
i seek out mentors who are
brilliant at what they do
and then one of my key questions always
is when you encounter failure or when
you encounter rejection what do you do
and because what i'm looking for are
strategies that i can apply to my own
life in my own career that keep me
moving forward
and um
and it's been incredibly invaluable
because
you you find that the higher up someone
goes as a writer or a director or
whatever or an actor
their fear is still there
but they have coping mechanisms where
the period that they're in um
breakdown
is shorter and shorter and shorter so in
other words for instance uh when
guillermo del toro was preparing to film
uh his dream project the mountains of
madness based on an h.p lovecraft novel
uh they pulled the plug on it universal
did because they thought it'd be too
expensive and r-rated and so forth and
and guillermo had other other irons in
the fire and immediately jumped over the
pacific rim and he was off and running
so that didn't mean he didn't feel
terrible and maybe had a weekend of
feeling very sorry for himself but he
got into motion and he was already
preparing for that eventuality
eventuality in advance so that he
wouldn't be stopped and
it's very important you know i think
don't be afraid of success
because success is very nice you know
when you write a book or that's
successful or a tv show that people talk
about for decades or
you get a big payday
those things are fine they're fine i
think people are often afraid of
scrutiny they're often afraid of well
i'm a fraud and i won't be able to
handle success but success is an
extremely amorphous thing you first of
all you can define what success means to
you for instance at this point in my
life i don't need to have the million
dollar payday you know i need to keep
working creatively and getting my work
out to an audience but money is not at
all what rules me i've made choices we
still live in an apartment we own our
two cars outright you know it's
i've made choices that allow my life to
be very um
free
in that way but um but for me success is
very very clear and i'm glad that i've
been successful
you know in i mean i i you know i can
look at my career and say well clearly
i've succeeded because i've created work
that people are still talking about you
know 40 years after i did it and also
i've earned significant money uh writing
for the studios and the networks until
space command i'd only written for the
studios and the networks and the major
publishers i'd never
done any independent film projects and
then
you know because of this roundtable i
mentor i started hearing about
crowdfunding and uh i thought well let's
see if i can raise money and turn out i
could
so
even though rod sterling was considered
a dashingly handsome confident man angry
at times maybe do you think he had a
touch of fear of success did he mask it
with the sort of the the this pretty boy
you know i don't think he was afraid of
success he was extremely charismatic
extremely confident without being
arrogant but
he felt that he had failed in his career
which is terribly sad the last interview
he gave
before he died at age 50 in in 1975
the interviewer said do you think you've
been
successful you do think you've you've
written work that will stand the test of
time and he said that the good writing
like fine wine has to age well with time
he said i think my work has been
momentarily um
adequate which is astonishing and so sad
that he didn't live
till now because he would have seen that
he had created one of the greatest
masterpieces of television and he had
inspired an entire generation of
showrunners i mean
every major showrunner in drama
rod is their hero he's the idol he's the
guy who sort of led the way as and um
it's really really sad that he didn't
get to uh to know that you know
i'm sure he would have been amazed and
extremely gratified
sure many other uh philip k dick
same thing fell okay dick was a
different case because he was um at
least he got to see philippe dick at
least got to see the footage from blade
runner he knew that somebody was
getting
um getting what he was doing and so he
um and he my god he created a huge
amount of work i mean he wrote i think
about 12 novels in a year plus short
stories i mean it's like uh let's hear
from amphetamines you know so
yes that i think that did help fuel him
but also he had his own what did he call
the hovel which was his sort of grungy
little yeah he was he was a talented man
he was very funny he was a troubled man
and there was all this whole thing of
how drugs drove him crazy and at the end
he was raving and and insane and all
that stuff and and i had dinner not long
ago with greg benford who's a fairly
conservative professor and also a
science fiction writer and i talked
we've got on the subject philip k dick
and he said oh no phil wasn't like that
at all he was very sweet very funny his
mind was perfectly together and he knew
him you know throughout the latter years
of his life and so i was very glad to
hear that because i think sometimes the
media can get an impression of someone
which isn't accurate and philip k dick
was an amazing writer and i'm glad that
that he had friends who really saw who
he was and valued that
what do you say to screenwriters who say
it's not their job to get the movie made
it's simply their job to write the
script have an idea and get that out
there well i
when people tell me they want to write
a script
i say to them
do you want to write a script or do you
want to make a movie because they're two
very different things
and early in my career i was friends
with charles jaffe who was woody allen's
agent and then his producer and i said
charlie and film and tv wears the power
he said in television it's the writer
producer hyphenate ideally the writer
executive producer hyphen at the show
runner
uh in films it's generally the writer
director hyphenate uh sometimes a
producer but often the writer director
and and that told me where to go in my
career i went into television because
writers run television and so that meant
that what i wrote would get made what i
wrote would get on the screen
i'd say 90 95 of what i've written has
been shot
and my friends who are screenwriters
have
lives of endlessly writing scripts for
these other people who
may or may not be
unstable but most of their work doesn't
get made and that i know the
screenwriters have worked for decades
and none of they've earned a good living
and none of their work has gotten shot
for me that would be a useless life
because
my goal is to create a body of work that
moves an audience that entertains an
audience that is meaningful to them and
uh
so you have to know what what you're
trying to accomplish so if a
screenwriter wants to be a screenwriter
doesn't want to be a director doesn't
want to be a producer then yes they can
write scripts but those scripts may not
sell or if they sell they may not get
made the way you wanted them to get made
or you may get fired or they may be they
may sell and be and never get made so
yeah if your goal is to make a living as
a writer there are a lot of different
ways to do that
or as an actor or as a director as a
producer but the more you say let's
chart a path
that
gets my work made and gets me an income
then that's a strategy
that allows you to be much more
effective
and and i'm not saying not to have a
career as a screenwriter i have friends
who've made millions and millions of
dollars
as screenwriters and they've had some
great films made um but you're a little
more thrown
to the the winds of fate
in that direction so
so one thing i would say to anybody who
wants to be a screenwriter is
get get mentors who are successful
screenwriters
because you must know what the rules are
because they don't tell you what the
rules are generally and unless you know
what the rules are unless you know the
secret language you will endlessly be
frustrated and the secret language we
all learn it because
in order to be successful you have to
know what like when you're in a room
pitching
you have to be able to read the room and
it's it's very funny because i once
ilene and i once went in and pitched
something
uh with someone who wasn't fair fairly
new to the business
and at the end of the meeting he came
out saying well um why didn't you say
this and this and this
and i said because we were saying it but
just not in words we knew
you know the person i was pitching to
knew that was under everything we were
saying and you know and and you also
know what's a yes what to know you know
where you have enthusiasm where you
don't um
there's there's a lot of ways to read
that stuff and and many of the
lessons many people are very frustrated
because they think they're succeeding
when they're not
because people in hollywood will act
like they're enthusiastic they'll love
your script they'll love your idea and
then suddenly they seem to blow a hot
and cold you know and it's because a lot
of people want to be liked but the
moment you're out of their sight they
forget about you and it's on to the next
thing and so you can never trust their
word
and um
so again that's why you don't want to
a lot of people think that well they
read the script they really liked it
that's
meaningless
it's like did they buy it
no
but they want me to come in again and
pitch again okay well that's not bad but
again it's sort of like
they really liked it but they didn't buy
it or they you know they when you go on
on audition and they say well um that
was great but you know thanks but if
they bring you back yes then you are
making an impact we have to really look
at
what a cause and effect because there
are a lot of things that people feel are
symbolic victories that are actually
not moving them forward and a real
victory is when something gets sold when
something gets made once you know and
when they hire you to do the next one
you know it's you can build
upon success
if you're consistently not succeeding
then you really have to look at what's
not working and find out why it's not
working but again you need to have
people who will tell you the truth but
be supportive no one has a right to say
to anybody you'll never make it no one
has the right to say to anybody you
don't have ability you're not you're not
good enough these are irrelevancies
the people who succeed in this business
are the ones who are incredibly
persistent my friend nicholas meyer who
directed wrath of khan he said the key
to success in hollywood is persistence
with charm
because you need the persistence to get
where you're going and the charm means
that they won't get pissed off at you
but um
but again i know so many people who
think it's like well i've written 10
scripts and none of them have sold
well you might try something that you
know i mean again if like often people
come to my round table and they've made
like 10 shorts or 15 shorts and i say to
them stop making shorts make a feature
because you can't you can't really make
a living doing shorts as far as i know
but if you take several shorts and link
them thematically
that can be put together into a feature
so you can do an ensemble film
made up of shorts if they're linked by a
character or a theme
or or any number of things or a location
and so start thinking that way because
if a feature is too big to do in one
gulp you might over a course of a year
be able to make three or four shorts put
them together as a feature and
then you're good to go and so
i i think
one really has to look at
where one's headed
and i think the keys to succeeding are
you have to write from the heart
learn your craft so that means either
that doesn't mean go to go to college
necessarily in screenwriting but it does
mean
read scripts see why they work see what
works and what doesn't be in writer's
groups where you get feedback but it has
to be supportive that doesn't mean it's
not critical but there's a lot of
toxicity you don't want um toxic notes
because they don't help you they just
put scars on your heart you know and
find mentors who who whose work you love
who have and who are authentic because
again as i've said before there are two
hollywoods there's a hollywood of creepy
horrible people
and then there's a hollywood of people
who are doing the work they love they
stand by their word they're good family
people and and they're good friends to
and they're they're authentic and that's
the hollywood you want to be part of
that's the hollywood you yourself want
to represent uh you do not have to
become a slime ball to make it in
hollywood that is there are many many
bad habits that people have you do not
have to a
become something you loathe and b i
strongly urge people to avoid working
with people they loathe you will not
just have one chance i mean if you're
if you
really put your heart and soul and a
work ethic into the into pursuing this
you'll find opportunities you'll make
opportunities um you don't have to be
the at the whim of someone crazy and nor
should you be
and uh but you also have to decide from
the beginning if you need to be rich
because if you need to be a millionaire
then yes the studios and the networks
are are the the road to take if you can
if you don't need to be rich well then
there's a million ways to earn money
writing books writing scripts you can
make uh films that earn some money earn
some money back you can have your own
youtube channel that brings in money
from ad revenue you there's a lot of
ways the patreon accounts i mean i know
people who are their art is being
supported by their patreon accounts and
uh
you know it's just
you you you need to talk to people who
are succeeding in the way you want to
succeed and say you don't ask them for
help you don't say get me an agent or or
open this door for me or or introduce me
to your friends no you ask advice
and and you say how did you do this or
what what when you when this happened
what did what what did you do and and
sometimes they'll give you answers that
you can apply and sometimes they'll give
you answers that you can't apply if you
can't apply it then keep asking the
question of different successful people
until you find the answer that you can
apply
and uh
and you know but there's there are many
different paths to success
and uh
and it's just
man you know rod sterling used to say i
when he when he would write scripts he
would say is this the truth as i know it
or better yet the truth is i feel it
and that's
words of wisdom
let's take another scenario and that is
someone's written what they think is an
amazing script it's been purchased and
too many hands got involved and quote
messed it up yes
and that happens often in fact i know
some writing team where they wrote a
horror script that they were very proud
of
and it got went through all these
different writers and they were very
worried about that and finally the
writers guild decided they would have
solo writing credit but then when movie
came out it was really terrible because
of all the rewrites and they were blamed
because theirs was the only name on it
and so you know
that's where i say
if you're willing to take power
if you're willing to take responsibility
if you say i'm going to write and
produce and direct
that doesn't mean you do it alone
you're not a one-man band but it means
that
you make sure that what you intended it
to be is what it is
you know because the moment you sell a
script
then
the moment you sell a script
you're at
you're no longer the boss the moment you
sell the script you no longer you no
longer have power whoever bought it has
power
and so
it can be any number of things anything
can happen to it it's like putting moses
in the in the little reed basket and
floating him down the nile you know it's
like bye kid
i mean will you become you know moses or
will you become pharaoh or will you
become like you know joe who
shines the statues you know
there's you have no power over that
anymore because you floated him away
that's like what people do with scripts
um
and so you know
when i was a writer on staff a writer
producer story editor
one of the things i would say at the
beginning of my job is i would say
my preference is that i not be rewritten
by others i will do as many drafts as it
takes but i prefer that my my work is
what gets to the audience
and because i was a hard worker and a
good writer um my bosses honored that it
was very rare that i would get rewritten
and uh
so
you know it's uh
you know you you work harder
but you um have less sleepless nights
you know
so uh but again it's
it's so easy to shoot stuff now it's so
you know i mean everywhere i turn you
know i see people shooting short films
or what or features or whatever t web
series tv shows you know it's
science fiction never predicted that we
would all have video cameras in our
pockets
and there's so many benefits of that
and you
know fear can stop you laziness can stop
you
you really have to say to yourself
if i have to work hard
it's worth it because i want
i want people to know what i'm doing i
want to share this with the world it has
to be that because otherwise if you're
going to be half-assed about something
then go work at mcdonald's you know
because if the fries are not the best
fries ever made then it's okay
but if you're going to make movies or tv
shows then then step up
there's only when you when you encounter
resistance or adversity you can either
step back or you can step up that's it
those are the only two choices and if
you step back you'll never know what
would have happened if you would just
really put your shoulder to the wheel
so you know i my career has been made by
hand
and i'm very proud of that
so you say with the fans give them kind
of what they want at the heart of the
story but then open the world wider is
that sort of like you know the saying i
know you better than you know yourself
which exactly because because
as i said earlier i'm i'm the same as my
audience so if i'm enthusiastic about
what i'm working on if i find a story
that interests me i'll be able to tell a
story i think that my audience will like
i never worry first of all i never talk
down to them i never worry about what
will please them
i'm just trying to tell a story that i
think is meaningful that meaningful from
a character standpoint um for instance
and i'm always writing about things that
i'm either um
you know love or frustrated about or
want to comment on but always it's
through the characters if the characters
don't work none of it works and
i'll give you an example i came up with
this idea called the show runners
network where i'm creating six science
fiction horror and fantasy series with
six major show runners so it's rocknell
bannon who created farscape and defiance
and seaquest and alien nation and cult
he's now ep on evil uh another
partnership i have on another one of the
shows with mark ferguson hawk ostby who
created inward showrunners on the
expanse and also did iron man and
children of men and so and then one of
them is a rod sterling project as well
and
so
so
when i started this project i sat down
and i wrote up 200 ideas for tv shows
and uh
and so every day i'd come up with 10
ideas and just write them down no
censorship at all
and uh
and so then rock rock new bannon and i
went down that list and and we saw what
sparked for both of us
and something a pet peeve of mine
is you know
now there are certain kinds of black
stereotypes you can't have on tv or
latino stereotypes or you know
misogynistic things right but older
actors
either are playing
coming down with cancer coming down with
dementia or the funny grandpa or the
funny grandma
and the seniors i know in my life and
the seniors that i i'm one of them now
um
these are vital involved engaged people
they are not those stereotypes and so i
was very frustrated with that so i came
up with an idea for a show called sweet
haven and ironically i came up with this
before the pandemic and the basic notion
is a a
bioengineered disease gets out of hand
and kills everyone in the world under
60.
and so the people 60 and above have to
figure out how to
keep humanity going when they can't
reproduce
and so it's a very fun idea so rock and
i worked up the plot line and elaine and
i wrote the pilot script from the
outline that rock and i had worked up
and then we cast it and it has robert
picardo from
star trek voyager and it's got barbara
bain from space 1999 and it's got gates
mcfadden from star trek the next
generation and mike harney from orange
is the new black and on and on it's
amazing veronica cartwright from alien
and the birds you know amazing amazing
cast and uh
and and they play these very interesting
and active characters james hong from
blade runners in it in big trouble
little in china but they are not going
to be playing with stereotypes they're
going to play be playing fully rounded
people in that world and so we've done
two table reads via zoom and we're gonna
shoot in the near future so um but again
it's just
i was excited about that idea and uh
the lovely thing when you can raise
money is that you don't have to worry
about oh is this something the networks
would buy i don't care frankly i mean if
they buy it great it makes my life
easier it gives me more money to play
with but
i don't at this stage of my life i don't
need approval i need
i need to be effective
so um it's a very different energy
the wonderful thing is as if you've
succeeded as you get older if you have
any
kernel of wisdom you stop competing with
other people and you just realize you're
here to find the truest expression of
your heart
that you can share with the world
and if people are moved by what you
create if they are
made better in some way even you know
entertainment is not is not something to
uh
to dismiss it's an important thing
um
you've succeeded you know i mean every
day i'm just trying to be
uh the best version of myself
and be open to i i love collaboration i
l the actors are my collaborators the
the designers are my collaborators
everyone and and even today when elaine
and i you know i direct with elaine
because elaine is a better director than
i am and she's an actor's director she
was a trained she was an actress and a
director off broadway and i'm an okay
director i'm good visually but um
but when elaine and i direct together
it's better it's better the work is
better the out the uh what comes out is
better and but what that allows me to do
for instance today we were looking at
sets and getting ready to shoot some
scenes we're gonna shoot in a few weeks
and elaine was
her vision was different from mine in
terms of how many people we have in this
scene or how many extras or and she
wanted fewer fewer tighter on the focus
on the scene and so i had to step back
from what i was attached to
my way of doing it my design in my head
i see the shots in my head
and say well let's let's let's see what
she has to say let's see what where
she's going with this let's see if it
works and that's a good
healthy creative instinct because it
lets in
the possibility of something better
and and because i'm not threatened
at all
um just grateful i can do that and so
when you stop
trying to
be
there's you're not in a race
you know
you're not trying to to beat anybody
else
you are just telling a story you are
just sharing
something that you love with other
people you know and
i was thinking about an interesting
uh analogy
yesterday where uh i heard someone
talking about quilting they made a quilt
for survivors of the people who died in
9 11 in the family and and i thought you
know it's funny no one ever talks about
pitching a quilt you don't go and meet
with a whole bunch of executives and say
hey i have an idea for a quilt and you
spend years just telling the idea of
what you have the idea you have for a
quilt and you never actually make a
quilt people would think you were out of
your mind right the point of
quilting is to make quilts and share
them with others
but writers in in tv and film they think
that that's an appropriate way to spend
their their lives to endlessly be
pitching and well i pitched this and it
didn't sell and i pitched that and it
didn't sell it's like why don't you just
make it make the thing you know get get
people together make make the work then
you're making the the the the quilt
you're quilting you're not talking about
a quilt someday you may get to make
and uh
you know it's it's so much more
rewarding and uh you know it's uh
i'm you know i'm just uh
i've got my feet planted on the ground
and and my head in the clouds
you know it's like
elaine keeps keeps my feet on the ground
but
but
there's such a lovely feeling of
accomplishment
when
you do something and it comes out the
way you want it and it goes out into the
world and people love it i mean even on
mr scifi we put out the first hour of
space command it's been seen by millions
of people and got 97 thumbs up well
that's great you know it's great to have
that it means that the people really
liked it and and uh
you know that that helps make me uh
eager for the next day and eager for the
next script were you always this way
where you just wanted to do something
that meant something to you that you
were excited by and you were staying in
your own metaphorical lane no
no i i was at the beginning of my career
you know i was very i i there was no no
certainty that i would make it and there
was always this
i mean i was very lucky because i i
started working writing my first book at
21 i sold my first short story at 19 and
i was running for tv by the time i was
22 or 23 and over the next 20 years the
longest period in that entire 20 years
that i was out of work was three months
and so i earned millions of dollars i
worked for all the major studios and
networks but but there was always a
sense that it could stop abruptly and it
actually did at one point and i had to
figure out a way of reinventing and re a
way of
getting things going again and
fortunately i was open to
new ways of doing things i i was very
open to that and so that's allowed me to
be where i am now but um
but i was not secure by any means i was
i was driven by a creative vision
and i loved writing other characters i
loved writing whether it was spock kirk
mccoy or whether it was the characters
in friday the 13th series or even the
smurfs whomever it was really fun to
write through those characters right you
know write what i wanted to say through
those those characters you have to be if
i can hear the voice of a character i
can write him you know i have to be able
to hear the voice but um
but i i was never that secure i was
never that certain that everything was
just going to cost along so i never felt
like i could just like take my hands off
the wheel um
going back what i probably would have
done some things differently my my
priority was always i always felt that
my obligation my creative obligation was
to my audience but i often didn't take
care of my bosses as well as i might
have you know i wasn't
i wasn't a worker among workers in a way
that i should have been and it's
fortunately i still was able to create a
body of work but um if i if i could go
back and change one thing i would be
much more um taking care of people in
that way and uh i've never been a
political animal you know i don't
care about those things and i have
worked with people who were
and i've also lost jobs to people who
were like one friend of mine was
recommending me to be a producer on this
show that he was creating
and
the producer who was running the show
didn't hire me and ultimately found out
what he was doing was he was only hiring
people who were his troops so he could
even eventually fire my friend because
he was political animal
and
and but at the time i thought well i
somehow said something wrong in the
interview no there was no way i was
going to get that job
but and my friend ended up out on his
ass you know and uh and that's when we
realized what it was all about but um
but i think i could have taken care of
people better you know and uh
i don't regret
in terms of the work i don't regret any
of the work i've done but but that's a
lesson that would have been good to have
learned sooner
yeah some people aren't good at flying
to politics no and i don't like kissing
the ass of people who are mediocre i
mean my the one thing that really
you know i was very open to people's
you know humanity but
i could never stand anyone who just said
well
it doesn't have to be great it doesn't
have to be good you know it's like we're
just here to make sausage i could i
could never never never stand that it's
like well you may be but i'm not i'm
here to make something wonderful that'll
last the test of time you either
understand the test of time
i i'm you know
i remember one time on sliders we were
someone pitched a clone story
and i said to my boss that story has
been done on every other show
every other science fiction show
and i started saying we shouldn't buy it
and he said well no but it hasn't been
done on our show and i said yes but the
audience isn't just watching our show
and the irony was that they bought that
script and i had to rewrite it you know
i rewrote and made it as good as i could
and but the thing was it's like had i
been making the choice of what we bought
and what we didn't buy i wouldn't have
bought that because it was cliche
already then it was cliche and i had to
fight that cliche when i rewrote it to
find some meaning in it but
but
it was a radically different philosophy
of how to make television because i know
from my own experience that a single
hour of television can change someone's
life forever for the better it's a huge
responsibility and i never never um duck
that responsibility i'm very cognizant
of it why do you like star trek better
than star wars the reason i like star
trek better than star wars there are
actually two answers to that i was 10
years old when star trek debuted and
that was the perfect age
for me to encounter that amazing
universe
i i sometimes joke that other people
love heroin i have star trek it was like
it was the thing i'd been waiting for
and i just loved it and it's been hugely
influential in my life star wars on the
other hand came out when i was in my
early 20s and so
if i'd been 13 years old when star wars
came out that would have been
my star trek you know and uh but it was
just i was just a little too old for it
to engage me in a way that would have
really been hugely meaningful i liked it
i thought it was a very very good film
but but also i like the star trek
universe better i think it has a lot
more opportunity for a wide variety of
stories i think it's
much more able to comment on
issues of the moment you know star trek
was deliberately written like twilight
zone these were gene roddenberry and rod
sterling were both men who had a lot to
say about
race about social issues about war
and uh and they said it and um
i think star wars is much more
kind of a
escapist entertainment i think it comes
from a very different place
but again it's not for me to
bad mouth anything i'm glad the
mandalorian has been successful i think
the more recent star wars films were
problematical because they kind of
didn't really know where they were going
and would go two steps to the left two
steps to the right and then you know
walk into a wall you know so it was like
um i feel very sad about that because
um
it could have been better and i i think
there's a problem when people decide
that they're going to
go
deviate from what's expected and go in
the exact opposite direction because
often
it doesn't create good art it just
creates
um
chaos
so i think you have to be very careful
of why you're doing making certain
creative choices because they if they
don't follow the emotional line um
that you're not going to engage in
audience
and also an audience that feels a
very
huge part of ownership yeah and the
story and the characters and that's and
that but the funny thing is the
audience's ownership of something is a
fine line to walk because you don't want
to just give them what they want because
then you're just reiterating the same
old story what you want is
to give them emotionally something
that's satisfying but also opens the
universe wider does something that they
haven't seen before but in an
emotionally satisfying way
so for instance when i came up with the
idea for far beyond the stars for deep
space nine it took us into the world of
1950s science fiction writers which was
something star trek had never done but
it showed the audience where we came
from why science fiction was important
why telling your truth is important and
it dealt with race in a very powerful
way and
i was very very glad that episode sold
and got made and people are still
complimenting me on it
20 years later people often don't know
what they'll love until they see it you
know and so
it's
like star wars you know if if they'd
tried to describe star wars before
people saw it i don't think people would
have understood what it was going to be
because it sounded like crap you know
this guy travels around with this big
hairy creature and you know and then
there's this guy in a mask and he's the
villain and he's you know
it would sound like jesus christ
and you know i want to be a jedi knight
it's like oh god but but then you see it
and what made star wars great was that
it was a visualization of everything
we'd been reading in science fiction for
decades but had never been visualized
that well
and so that's what set it apart
it wasn't that it was enormously
original it was that it was
transferring to film what had been we'd
been reading about forever but had never
seen on film so that was what made it so
exciting you know flying through the
asteroid belt and all those wonderful
things the laser battles and you name it
it was it was great fun it's one of the
most entertaining films ever made
so yeah
what do you think the new star wars
trilogy got wrong
that's a hard one it wasn't for lack of
trying because i know j.j abrams and i
know he loves star wars and
i think he was afraid of of blowing it
but but he certainly put everything he
had into it and he certainly did a lot
of things right i mean the you know
building a full-size millennium falcon
for instance but um
star wars has a very limited bag of
tricks it's like there's the good guys
the jedi knights the bad guys the the
new order or or you know the the
whatever you know
it's like good guys versus bad guys and
the bad guys have a weapon and they're
going to blow something up and you know
it's like it's so difficult and because
you and then mandalorian has expanded
that a bit they put a baby in a baby
yoda but um
uh you know it's just
there's so many ways i mean i thought i
thought jj was very clever with his
version of star trek a lot of people are
down on that version but i think he
actually did a very good job of bringing
it alive again and finding a way of
reinventing it um
but with star wars it's like
who are those people who is who is a
kylo ren who is you know i mean he kills
harrison ford we're never going to
forgive him for that i mean it's not
like darth vader comes around at last
and saves his son which is a great story
arc it's like kylo ren put the
lightsaber through harrison ford and he
fell down and he was dead you know it's
like
you know
you it doesn't go somewhere that you
want it to go i don't care if rey and
kylo ren are drawn to each other i don't
know who those people are you know and
they're like they're like less
interesting versions of the characters
that we started with you know with luke
and leia and han it's like you don't
i mean like poe dameron who is that guy
why do we i mean i like the actors very
much i think the actors generally are
extremely good but it's just
you know where
where are you going you know it and and
then so it basically the first move goes
like this then the second movie goes
like that and then they try and jam it
back this way
it doesn't it doesn't flow it doesn't
pay off well at all it's just
weak storytelling and uh
but but again when you view a property
as a cash cow
then you just try to get your best
people and try and hope that one out of
every three or four will click
and because that keeps the franchise
alive
and
it's a cynical
way of looking at things and certainly
not
[Music]
creative
but it's a machine it's factory but um
that doesn't mean you can't get great
star wars stories or great star trek
stories or any of this stuff some you
know it's like each time out
it's the luck of the draw it's not that
people are trying to create crap they
aren't they're trying to really do a
great job and if it fails it's it fails
simply because
what they tried or the direction they
went didn't didn't pay off i think you
know uh kevin feige's done a great job
with the marvel universe he's made a lot
of great great films i'm not a huge fan
of marvel but i recognize the artistry
of what he's done
you need someone at the top of the food
chain who really kind of has a vision
whether that's rod sterling or gene
roddenberry whomever you need that
person who kind of keeps it on track and
it's hard to find those people they're
very rare if you were put in charge of
the star wars trilogy
how would you have approached it
i i would have tried my best to make it
good
no i mean here's my real feeling about
star wars in terms of speaking as a
creative artist
i think
the truly the structure of the first
trilogy
is very solid
and uh but the ewoks by the time you got
to return to the jedi george lucas
decided he was making films for children
not broad-based family entertainment in
other words there's an adult there's a
certain adult quality to the first two
films that the third film with the ewoks
and all that it's like let's make some
teddy bears let's let's make some
products and then when he went to the
prequels
he needed
you know he was writing them he needed a
writer who was solid he needed to bring
in a strong writer because this the
basics of the story
you know the fact that that the best
jedi becomes
um
evil and is and then ultimately rises
the occasion to save his son those first
six films that structure is really
interesting but the telling of it was
very poor and so
first of all it was as i say they were
films for children and they were kind of
silly but also the writing was really
poor the dialogue was really poor the
design stuff was great my friend ian
mckay designed darth maul but
um but they did but also when you when
you're thinking of it all as something
that's going to help sell toys
then you're not thinking oh well look
here's this great character darth maul
why don't we give him a personality and
why don't we have him continue longer in
the show in the you know in the series
of films he was great when ray park is
fighting two guys off with you know with
one lightsaber you know it's astonishing
when he i mean he's great and they cut
him in two i would have had him you know
stuck back together and come on back you
know it's but um
but i think
there's a lot of weird vibes in those
first three films it's like hey look
you're a 10 year old kid and i'm going
to marry you in the next movie it's like
holy cow here's a babysitter and then
you you know next thing you know you're
in bed with him it's like what you know
it just gives you a creepy feeling you
know um
and and also of course that kid couldn't
really um act much and you know so it's
just
lost opportunity
what do you love about star trek
discovery
doug jones i think is terrific he's the
lead in space command as well or one of
our one of our lead actors and he's
absolutely wonderful
um
i think the production design is pretty
amazing i think the detail on sets and
costumes is pretty amazing the visual
effects are good i think it's it's gone
kind of i haven't watched all of the
third season yet but i felt the first
couple of seasons were pretty weak in
terms of
uh just characterization and and
storyline
um i you know there's
there's a lot of talent in that cast but
i i would have i would have developed
the characters very differently i would
have um
gone much deeper
i think that there's a very hit-and-miss
quality to a number of the characters
where it's like who are these people and
what what's the point of this story and
i think they're often talking about the
emotion without actually dramatizing the
emotion and um
so i
you know strange new worlds may be the
star trek episode the show we're all
waiting for that's the ones captain pike
the fun part about that is captain pike
was the original captain the first pilot
that gene roddenbee did of star trek in
1964.
and so if that and now that's being
greenlit as a show so it's the longest
period for when a show was pitched when
a pilot was made to when they actually
picked up the show it's like 55 years or
60 years that's pretty fun
how do you think gene roddenberry would
have felt about star trek today
i think he would be have very mixed
feelings i think he'd be very glad that
was still generating
billions of dollars
and still popular i think i don't think
he would necessarily be that fond of
star trek discovery
or picard simply because
they
are missing the opportunity of telling
stories that have
relevance to the current moment you know
i think he was very
very much someone who wanted to
make emotional points that related to
the real world and i think star trek
discovery and picard have been
they kind of have sorts they're kind of
drifting a little bit i you know and uh
it so i don't think you'd necessarily
like those shows particularly
but that's not for me to say
you know ask him when they clone him you
know
what's your argument that star trek is
better than star wars well my argument
is i wouldn't say that star trek is
better than star wars i would just say
that it's different
i you know it's
my friend mel gilden
says the golden age of science fiction
is 13.
and of course by that he means that when
you're a 13 year old that's when you
find those things in science fiction
that really speak to your heart
and the universes you want to live in uh
it's just for me
i remember when i was a kid i recorded
the original broadcasts of star trek on
reel-to-reel tape in case the show never
aired again and there were no vcrs
there's no way to you know record the
entire show where you can watch it um
but i remember that week after week
after week there were stories
that i'd never seen anywhere before they
were astonishing and they had such
profound meaning
for my life you know i remember a city
on the edge of forever
where kirk and spock and mccoy go back
to the 30s and kirk falls in love with
this woman who runs a soup kitchen and
ultimately he finds out that in order
for the time
um flow of time to turn out correctly
she has to die
and
so he literally allows her to be hit by
a truck he throws her into a truck
and
every tv show i'd ever seen before that
the hero saved the girl it was just a
given and in this one
he's responsible for the death of the
girl
and and the message was sometime in your
life
there'll be something you know is the
right thing to do
but it'll break your heart but because
it's the right thing to do you have to
do it
and i was profoundly changed by that one
episode that harlan ellison wrote
and um
and i and and so star trek had a deep
deep formative
influence on me
and whereas i can't say that luke or
leia or obi-wan or any of those
characters as much as i like them
changed me in any way particularly other
than entertaining me for a few hours
so
so i'm not
i think if someone thinks that star wars
is better than star trek more power to
them i i think it's fine for anyone to
have any opinion basically as long as it
doesn't hurt anyone you know i think
compassion has to be what rules us and
it's it's so liberating
when you don't need to be right
you know when you say this is just my
opinion if you have a different opinion
it's fine that does of course that
doesn't mean racism or misogyny or any
of those things you have to speak out
against things that are really hurting
people but most opinions are just people
having opinions you know is star wars
better than star trek i don't know not
for me but for other people sure it's
fine like when jj abrams loves star star
wars you know i mean
you know i'm sure that he feels really
bad that he wasn't able to uh to do
everything he wanted to do with it you
know so
luck of the draw
it reminds me a little bit of the keith
richards biography where he talked about
a lot of these jazz enthusiasts and
there were two different types there
were the ones that were sort of schooled
uh in the bars and and had learned to
play yes by ear and then there were
others that had these theories and they
would argue it and
the film world feels like that at times
yes well i have i have very little
patience with theorists you know it's
funny uh you know i think of the
twilight zone companion as an oral
history of the twilight zone i
uh was very lucky that all all the
writers directors producers actors were
alive with very few exceptions i mean
rod sterling was gone one of the other
writers charles bowman was gone but most
everyone else was alive and so i was
able to get the direct story from the
people who made these shows who wrote
them and directed and produced them and
the cinematographer and so forth and uh
but when you have theorists it's like i
don't really want to hear people's
theories i don't care about that it's so
academic and so pointless i would rather
hang out with people making something as
opposed to people commenting about
something
and it's funny because when i wrote the
twilight zone companion i wrote it to
learn how to be a writer producer in
television not
and so then when people offered me gigs
to write books about other tv shows i
always said no because that wasn't why i
did that book i didn't do that book to
then write the making of mash or the
making of you know uh
hello kitty or whatever you know any of
anything you know
my little pony but um
you know so i
and and it's funny because on dvds and
blu-rays i'll always listen to the
commentaries of the directors or the
writers of the sh of the film or tv show
but when it's some guy some theorists
like he's the head of the film
department at you know some university
and he has this this theme about
alienation or whatever it's like i don't
go away
you know it's not it's not worth my time
and it's not of interest to me
that doesn't mean that you can't have
larger meanings or metaphors or any of
that
but ultimately for any film
or tv show or book or any work of art to
have relevance it has to touch you here
it has to move you emotionally
we love van gogh not because
of the theory of what he's doing we love
ango because those paintings speak to us
they move us
and uh you know so that's the one thing
i do like about the modern age
is authenticity
is valued now so for instance
if people recognize me as an authentic
person and that my work is in alignment
with who i am as a person or the people
i mentor the run the roundtable i run if
everything i do from mr sci-fi to the
round table to space command to all
these things are all
um
in a line they all speak to the same
compassions they speak to the same
kindness
people recognize that i'm authentic in
what i say and do
and i'm very glad that that matters
because when i started my career
the only time someone in the audience
would encounter something of some work
of mine is by reading a book i'd written
or watching a tv show i might get a fan
letter or maybe meet someone at a
convention now
the audience is directly in
communication with me and i actually
like that
because it tells me i'm i'm on the right
path because i know and i don't need
the fans i don't need the fans to tell
me what to do artistically
but it's nice to know that what i'm
setting out to do is being accomplished
so it's great
well that's the problem it's people who
are in the ivory tower people who are i
mean particularly like it's like people
who didn't know anyone who made that
film or anyone who made that tv show
it's like you know some expert on howard
hawks but he didn't know the guy and
free and frequently they'll come up with
all these reasons why something was done
that has nothing to do with why it was
really done it could be they were losing
the light so that's why he shot it as a
one or you know like one with without
cuts you know it might not have been a
stylistic choice it might even the light
was gone or you know there's always
things that come out great through the
wonderful
chaos that production is
um
you know you always see the lovely see
if i wanted total control over what i
was doing i'd be a novelist
because novelists can sit in their
little rooms and the universe can be
exactly the way where they want it in
their work and then they give it to the
editor and they can take those notes or
not take those notes
but they're sort of the god of that
universe they create
i love to collaborate i love what actors
bring in my work what what designers
bring my work what everyone brings to my
work i love collaboration because
there's such an element of surprise if
you
choose people who are talented and
brilliant and
passionate the work they come up with
will surprise you when an actor takes a
for instance there was a in the pilot of
space command there was a monologue i
wrote for bob picardo where he talks
about the death of his wife
and when i wrote it
i said this probably won't work
but i'll try it and i can always cut it
out and then bob delivered it and it's
astonishing it's wonderful and
and so i was really glad i trusted my
actors and said okay i'm not convinced
let me see what he can do with it
and he surprised me because he really
went somewhere
truthful and
you know and that was that was me
partnering with someone who made my work
better
so i i have nothing but gratitude
what makes the twilight zone different
from everything else
quality
it's good um okay
the twilight zone is
possibly the best television show ever
made
i think there's an argument argument
that can be made for that
rod sterling never wanted to be a
science fiction writer he wanted
basically to be the arthur miller of
television
and
when he was censored when he couldn't
write about politics when he couldn't
write about race there were so many
things he wanted to write about and the
censors just would not allow it
and his work he felt his work was being
turned into meaningless crap
because of these uh limitations he
thought well if i do science fiction
maybe i can slide these things past and
they won't notice what i'm actually
doing and that that's worked it worked
exactly he he ended up writing four
pilot scripts for the twilight zone
before the show got greenlit he was very
determined to uh to have that happen
and um
so i think it came from the fact that
this was a man who had a lot to say
and knew how to say it
uh twilight zone just isn't about the
gimmick the gimmicks are great and the
twist endings and all of those things
are wonderful and the fact that it was
science fiction and a horror and fantasy
allowed it to be universal in a way that
had he just been writing about
you know
ed medgar evers or something it wouldn't
have been you know because then it would
seem very dated and the writers from
that era of live television generally
are not well known you know tad moselle
or reginald rose or even patty chayebsky
had sterling stayed in live tv
and not created twilights and he'd
probably be forgotten now as good as
requiem for heavy weight was or patterns
but
but because he was forced to write in
this wonderful
genre
and write on universal themes fear
alienation you know loss of identity um
it just created these amazing stories
and his scripts were so good that they
would get the top actors actors who
often wouldn't do television and uh and
you got bernard herman and jerry
goldsmith these amazing composers and
george clemons this phenomenal uh
cinematographer it's just
you look at the best episodes of the
twilight zone there are a lot of them
and you're just
you hold your breath they're so
beautiful in every way
and timeless and
um and they work and even when you know
what the story is you're moved by these
people because rod had a genuine
sympathy and empathy for the little guy
for someone working in as a bank teller
or a woman who's a secretary or you know
he's not writing generally about
presidents or kings or wealthy people uh
he doesn't even though he himself was
one of the best paid writers in
television he's not fawning he doesn't
um
idolize the rich like some writers have
he's some he's a regular guy he's a you
know he's you can get the sense that he
has this big heart he really cares
deeply and he's coming from the heart
and again when i was talking a few
minutes ago about authenticity you know
rod when you see rod sterling on
television he's exactly that guy i mean
i've seen videos of him teaching classes
where he wasn't he knew these wouldn't
be broadcast and he was absolutely
himself warm and funny and smart and and
caring and uh and that really comes
across on twilight zone this is a man
saying here's a story i want to tell and
i'm sharing it with you or here's these
other writers that i've brought aboard
who have these wonderful stories to
share with you it's his gift to the
audience and
it holds up because it's not
about something trivial the twilight
zone is about something profound deeply
profound and its meaning conveys
to the younger generation as much as to
the audience it was made for back in
1959.
have you seen every episode oh yeah
okay what would you say the top five
i've actually when i when i started
writing the twilight zone it was two
years twilight zone companion it was two
years after rod's death and carol
sterling his widow
was still living in the house in pacific
palisades his dog was there this irish
setter and all these everything was
exactly as he'd left there was one room
that was just the awards the six emmys
and the peabody awards and on and on um
and so in the garage there were film
cans his film cans of twilight's on
episode 16 millimeter prints it was part
of his contract that he would get two
prints of every episode because there's
no vcrs there was no home recording back
then so often i would go home with a
stack of these film cans and put them on
the projector and they had the original
commercials in the original coming
attraction spots and many of these had
never even been put through a projector
they were just pristine they were
gorgeous and
so yeah and there were
four episodes that weren't in
syndication and then there was an a
season and 18 episodes that were
hour-long episodes that weren't
generally syndicated every now and then
they'd pop up but um yeah i i had to do
a little bit of uh pursuing some of
these episodes that were not in the uh
in the general audience though one of
the funniest stories in that regard was
that i uh i was researching the twilight
zone companion and this was just as vcrs
were starting to become available for
purchase but they weren't widely
available so i recorded the episodes off
the air on reel to real tape i'm on
cassette tape and rod didn't have copies
of every episode it got more and more
hit and miss as the seasons went on and
so at one point they were like i think
two episodes that i could just not two
or three episodes that they just never
aired on ktla
so which was syndicating twilight zone
so i called the station manager
and i said listen i'm doing a book
on uh on the twilight zone and i there's
three episodes i need to see and i want
to find out when you're going to be
airing them because i really need to see
them he said well what episodes are they
and i told him he said well
we'll broadcast them next week so all of
la watched the episodes just because i
needed to see them oh wow
i thought he was going to just have me
in and maybe screen them for me but nope
everybody got to see him and so that was
that was really funny and wonderful but
uh but it was great that i was able to
do to produce the blu-ray set and do 52
commentaries and and now of course i'm
going to do the the rest of them 104
that are left and uh so people will be
able to buy
buy all of them so they'll be able to
hear everything i know about twilight
zone and
for all of the episodes it's going to be
great fun
if you had to choose what would be the
top five
i love walking distance which was rod's
personal favorites about a man who goes
back in time to his own childhood it's a
wonderful episode
um on thursday we leave for home which
is a great episode that rod wrote with
james whitmore it's one of the hour ones
uh i have the eye of the beholder which
is the woman whose head is wrapped in
bandages waiting to see if she's been
made to look normal
um
nightmare twenty thousand feet which is
the gremlin on the wing with william
shatner that richard donner directed
it's a great episode
um i mean i could i could list 20 i mean
and um it's a good life with billy mummy
that's a great one where he's got the
power to do to terrorize a small town um
but again i could easily pick you know
death ship miniature there's so there's
so so many in praise of pip um
you know there's just it just goes on
and on time of last with burgess
meredith is the last man on earth um
there's just i mean week after week
after week after week it was an
astonishing artistic feat what he was
what he was pulling off it was uh
no one has ever really equaled it i
don't think
what's your writing process
i work five days a week minimally
sometimes six sometimes seven but i
prefer not to
uh
i'm
always
thinking about a story or
there's always something going on here
in my head i don't have regular writing
hours at various times i have but now
because i'm writing and producing and
directing and doing books as well
um my day is split up into smaller
chunks and i'm often doing
many different tasks in a given day
uh because i have full-time editor
full-time um you know line producer
vfx team all of that um
so
when i sit down to write i try to write
for several hours minimally i
but i but it's like you know i but i can
also write on the fly if i need to i can
write
almost anywhere i can write in a moving
car i've written in jeeps traveling
through the jungle in thailand when i
did a pilot for nbc that was shot there
i mean
it's like
i
i'm often working on several scripts
simultaneously
i'm always reading several books uh at
the same time and then i'll come up with
ideas and i'll jot them down i'll save
those and sometimes i'll i'll um
i'll write them or i won't i mean one of
the ideas i came up with recently that i
liked was um well two two i came up with
that i liked one was
i heard about the slave revolt in haiti
where they actually succeeded you know
in freeing themselves and i thought what
would have happened if before the civil
war that it happened in america that had
spread to america and then now it's the
modern day and there's a separate
country of free of of the descendants of
freed black slaves so the south it's
like it's not the confederacy one won
the civil war and we've got two americas
it's that there's a black nation
where those slaves freed themselves and
what would that look like and what would
our country look like and that was an
interesting idea and another idea i came
up with which was rather amusing was
just a short story where someone would
have a chance to go back in time one
time and there's an artist who never got
his due was never recognized for his
talent and died without knowing that
anyone would would you know cared about
his art he'd been rejected a lot during
his lifetime so he goes back and
convinces the official um
art
authorities to like take him in and
accept him and do shows of his paintings
and so forth and the way it would be
structured is we would believe
throughout the story that it's vincent
van gogh but in the end it's adolf
hitler because if hitler had succeeded
as an artist right he never would have
gone into politics he wouldn't have
there'd be no nazi party none of that
and so it just it just struck me as a
funny story that that hitler had he just
been appreciated for his artwork
it would have really changed that
century so it was just a but but again
so i come up with many many ideas like
for instance when i mentioned sitting
down to come up with 200 ideas it's
actually up to 300 now ideas for movies
or tv shows where i just jot them down
and and um
and sometimes i'll i'll i'll pursue them
it varies there are certain ideas that i
definitely will write like with space
command i knew i was going to do that
and i knew that i would write the entire
season which which i have um and then
we'd shoot it so um
but
i'm always
working on something i'm never lying
fallow um and
some scripts it's like
like over the next few months we'll be
rewriting this the final six hours of
season one of space command but meantime
i plan to write you know i mean we're
also gonna write and shoot all all the
other five pilots of the show runners
network um you know and so that's so
we've written sweethaven now and again
it's always just
who are the characters what is the idea
how does this move how does this grow
what is it saying you know but it's
always through characters i mean it's
you know with with sweet haven part of
the genesis that was my friend michael
harney he's in project blue book he's in
orange is the new black he's in um for
all mankind
and yet he never gets these wonderful
lead roles that he should and so i said
well how would you like to play a cop
and be the lead in sweethaven where all
the people under 60 die and but i also
created his brother who will also be
playing who went the exact opposite path
and is very s
dangerous
and i thought that would be fun too
because i have my physical trainer who
i've been with for 30 years elaine and i
both um he had an identical twin brother
who was very very different from him and
so that became of interest to me so it
isn't just using a cliche from soap
operas you know of the twins the good
twin and the bad twin it's just the
interesting thing of someone who goes
very different from someone who looks
like him you know it's just fun and and
then you know so it's but um but any
given week i'm writing i'm
you know working in my producer capacity
so i'll be meeting with my vfx team and
reviewing vfx shots i'll be marketing
i'll be doing the mr sci-fi stuff i'll
be building my audience it's all part of
the job you know it's all you know i am
you know in directing i mean today we
were just you know getting the sets
ready to get them get them up and
running you know so it's exciting it's
fun
when you were riding in the jeep through
the jungles of uh
oh you were typing yeah i can type in a
moving vehicle
and so this wasn't on like a legal pad
you were actually okay yeah yeah i can
write it on on a legal pad but but it's
easier to type in a moving vehicle um
because when you're jostled and you're
trying to write you kind of you know do
that but um but i'm very fortunate i
think it's because when i was a kid i
read books my mom would have me in the
back seat and i would read voraciously
and i think the fact that i
did that all you know kind of meant that
i'm not i don't get carsick and so um so
yeah and and often i've had to write um
under deadline in those kind of
circumstances i can write with music
playing i mean i can be in like a busy
coffee shop or something and i'm not
distracted
so
you know i just go into that world you
know and
you know so it's very fun
how did you figure out your writing
process
well
um
in television you have deadlines and so
you just have to get very you write very
fast you'll have maybe a week or two to
write an entire script the hardest
i have i ever had the hardest experience
was i had to write two hour scripts in
one week for two different series there
was one period of three months where i
was writing i think nine scripts for six
different shows
and
and i could juggle between outlining i'd
be outlining one while writing the
script for another but there were two
shows they would not budge on the
deadline and so the way i did that was
i would write 10 pages of one in the
morning have lunch to clear my head then
write 10 pages the other one in the
afternoon and i did that for six days
straight so at the end of six days i had
two 60 page scripts and one was forever
night and the other was space precinct
and they both got shot they both got
made
and
and then another time i wrote 55 pages
in one day
which was for
i think an animated show called black
star and elaine was a faster typist that
was back when we were on typewriters and
so i was writing the pages freehand and
handing them to a lane she was typing
and at the end of the day i had the
entire script written
so and that got made too of course and
so
there's something there's a very
different energy where you know that
everything you write will get made
it's it's then it becomes very pragmatic
it's not like you you know you don't you
don't wait for inspiration you put in
the work you just you know it's like if
i have to write an entire script over a
weekend i can i will i prefer not to
you know but um but i find that
qualitatively there are scripts that
i've written in a week that were every
bit as good as scripts that took me a
year
and you know so i'm
you know it's i'm i i have faith in my
abilities after all this time i know
what i can do
um
though
you have to know
the story you're telling
because
you can't afford to get lost
in your script it can't go south you
have to know that's why outlining
particularly in tv is so important
because you have to know what what the
structure is what how it tracks that
doesn't mean you can't um
depart from that if you know you're
going somewhere
better but you just can't there's not a
lot of room for that wild
experimentation you know so
but um but but usually
i find that i'm my i'm clearest in terms
of my writing in the afternoons so i'll
usually write in the afternoons but
i can write any time that i need to
write you know if i'm under the gun
and uh
i remember one time when we were
shooting the first hour of space command
bob picardo mentioned that i referenced
the wizard of oz in an early scene that
he had with doug jones but i didn't pay
it off and so we were going to be
shooting
that like a few days later and i woke up
in the morning
with the entire scene in my head uh that
paid off the wizard was and so while so
i said to elaine you drive
and so while we were driving to the
studio i typed the scene
and then when we got to the studio i
went into the office and said print this
out then i gave it to doug and to bob
and that that day we shot it
so but that was because bob was right he
had a great um note and but it was just
like but that's how sometimes the
process is like that
um other times you know it's uh other
times you'll have to go through draft
after draft after draft and uh and
hopefully find find your way you know
but but tv has a much shorter um
uh
you know runway
so you better be able to take flight
when you run out of you know the the
landing strip you know it's you you
better be able to hit the air and uh
i but that's why but i love the speed of
television and i love the fact that most
the what what you write gets made you
know it's uh i never could have had a
happy life as a screenwriter i don't
think that would have been for me at all
well that was my next question is what
would your advice be to someone who
doesn't have the advantage of a deadline
they are their own deadline yes and and
they are their own audience for a while
work with a timer that's what i do
um we all have timers in our in our
phones
so say okay i'm going to write you have
to write on a regular basis you have to
have a discipline
and it's not so if you say
um
my writing hours are going to be from
9 a.m to 12 you know noon
and and you find a space where you're
not going to get distracted
you find a writing space it could be at
a starbucks it could be a corner of your
home it doesn't matter where it is but
it's that's your writing place and
people know it's your writing place and
they know that your time that's your
writing time and it's sacrosanct you
don't do other stuff in that in those
hours and you set your alarm for three
hours or two hours or one hour whatever
it is and you sit there and even if
nothing comes you sit there you do the
work and um and you treat it just like a
job just like if you're working at a
shoe store you know you're working for
yourself but you cannot just watch tv
you cannot go you know um
you know talk with your pals no you're a
writer and
uh but also setting a deadline for when
a draft will be done is very important
so you just say okay uh three weeks from
now i'm going to have a draft written it
doesn't have to be good it just has to
be
this beginning middle and end and then
you can go back and revise but just you
just you
go you know and if and
but
professional writers need to treat it
like a job the best schedule of anyone i
ever knew was ray bradbury he would
write five days a week he would get up
in the morning right um until lunch time
then he would have lunch then he would
take a nap and in the afternoon he would
attend to business
and then evenings and weekends were for
the family and he did that for over 70
years
so pretty phenomenal well these
wonderful things that we have in our
pockets to shoot film also are a
distraction and now we can check news
and now everything that we're interested
in is now going to be reflected back
over and over again and you have to be
careful i mean again you can
lose yourself
in all of these pursuits but ultimately
at the end of the day it's like
how committed i am to say
how committed am i to what i say i want
and because at the end of the day the if
you don't believe it no one else will
and the only way they can believe it is
if you get things finished if you get
things out there if you
i
you know i mean nobody ever says i want
to be a brain surgeon but i want it to
be really easy
you know it's they know that you you put
in work you know it's like and but but
people think that writing is going to be
easy it's not some days it's easy some
days it's hard but
fortunately
if you're doing it right the audience
can't tell what was hard and what was
easy which is fun which is really fun um
when it's easy when it's good
and and it comes easily it is good you
know i'm not deluding myself when it's
hard though
i can struggle and struggle and if i
nail it ultimately
the audience has no idea that was
difficult it flows
you know so that's
a relief
so uh but you know it's
but you know it's
the script is just the blueprint the
script is just the arrow pointing the
way you know i i don't
i mean for instance i have to decide
like today we were having an actress try
on one of the costumes to see if it
worked we were deciding if she would be
on a bed in this hospital room or if she
would be in like this this um you know
uh
cylinder thing uh that would be like
with tubes plugged in and things and
computer panels and stuff and so it's
like that's part of the writing process
too uh determining what the lighting is
going to be is it going to be subdued is
it going to be bright what color is it
going to be what lens are we going to be
using these are all creative decisions
um
you know i've been acquiring uh like i
own i think 14 or 15 spacesuits now you
know so i acquire them from different
productions or my mom got me one when i
was a kid and um
and then you redress them i get sets
from the best place to get sets from is
big budget science fiction movies that
tanked because no one saw them and the
production design is great and then you
you redress them so they're yours but it
gives you this level of
um just artistry and and detail and they
because they put so much money into it
so you um so that's and that's a trick i
learned from rod sterling because when
he shot twilight zone at mgm he used
every prop and costume and set that they
had you know
and when i was a producer at sliders on
sliders at universal i said can i use
everything from every universal
production ever made and they said huh
no one's ever asked that let me find out
and they came back and they said with a
very few exceptions yes and we were
using stuff from jurassic park and time
cop and 12 monkeys and on and on it was
fabulous uh the best little whorehouse
in texas we shot one of our episodes in
that house
so
but you know it's um
i'm in the business of being
ingenious
and so the more i come up the more i
pull a rabbit from a hat the more that i
come up with a clever idea the more i
say okay this is
this is the way to get where we're going
um it's a series of problems that need
to be solved but it's a joyous process
and
i mean to take something that's just in
your head and put out in the world so
everyone can see it
it's just
it's just there's no there's nothing
like it it's wonderful when when it
comes together it's great you know i uh
i love that process and i feel part of a
tradition i feel in a way that rod
sterling and harlan ellison and all
these wonderful people who
inspired and and
guided me i'm part of that
tradition the reason i like to mentor
people
is because
i feel that i can then pass on what i've
learned from from these amazing people
and
it doesn't end with me
i'm just part of the part of the process
part of the flow
have you ever mentored someone or met
someone that you could just tell they
weren't going to be teachable
yes i have and uh and the lovely thing
is i don't ever assume that i have to
succeed with anybody like one of the
rules of my round table when i started
was there's no any everyone is welcome
if they come with a good heart there's
no decision as to who's deserving notice
no decision as to who has talent or
who's going to make it or not if someone
comes with a good heart
writers producers actors directors
editors composers anybody they're
welcome because we're creating a
community a supportive community um when
i mentor people if they're just not
going to get it i just stop talking
because it's sort of like you know this
when they'll say well this is what i'm
going to do and i'll say well that's
probably not going to work
you know i don't and i'm not usually not
that blunt but i'll say well you know
here's a few other ideas that would i
think be easier
to make happen and if they just are
resistant to that they say okay well go
with god and also if they come back and
say i did that and it worked i'll say
great you know because again i don't
need
to have there's no there's no one way
to do it there's a lot of ways to fail
of course you know giving up is a really
bad idea because when you give up it
guarantees that nothing's gonna happen
but if but you can't just keep failing
and failing and failing you figure out
what's going wrong some people can't
write and if you can't write but you
want to make film or make tv then
they'll affiliate with someone who's got
the talents you don't have and do what
you can do do what you're good at
some people for instance guillermo del
toro told me he's not great with
dialogue so he you know he's good with
plot good with imagery my god but so he
affiliates with people who write
dialogue well um
you know you find the person like when i
mentioned earlier that i direct with
elaine
could i learn the skills that elaine has
to work with direct with actors yes i
could i could learn those skills and i'm
not terrible i mean i can i can work
with actors i do know what the what the
through line emotionally is and so forth
but but elaine having been an actor and
gone to drama school and directed off
broadway she has a depth of
uh she has a bag of tricks that i don't
have but but because i'm collaborating
with her i don't have to learn that
stuff because she has it so i can say
well
how do we get this how do we get this
effect how do we get this actor to do
this thing and she'll then talk to them
and it's like wow great you know so
um and sometimes it's miraculous to me
like it's like how did you do that
so good you know and uh so that's that's
really fun but on the other hand i had
to teach her to like not think of it
like directing a play it's like look at
the monitor see that angle is not a good
angle
so like turn them this way
you know and now now she's much more
savvy to to camera angles and all that
kind of stuff so we we learn from each
other
can you explain why outlining matters to
all the screenwriters who
are set against it yeah i mean
you don't want to outline such a degree
that you have no juice left for the
script you know it's not
it's not
like building a concrete wall around
yourself that you can't break out of
it's basically to give you the bones of
structure
so you know where your story is going
now in television outlining is much more
important because if you're under the
gun if they're going to be shooting in
three weeks or two weeks or tomorrow you
you can't go off into left field you
have so that's when outline really needs
to be nailed down um in features
see but what what this really speaks to
is you need to you need to know
understand how structure works you know
because structure i early in my career i
struggled a lot with structure and then
there was one period one summer where i
was writing i think all the episodes of
a series for cbs and um i was writing so
much and so quickly all of a sudden it
just clicked in it was like it went
right into the groove and suddenly
structure was simple for me it was just
like built it was like the bones of a
house and the bigger the story the
bigger the house but it's like the
framework that holds it all together and
i understood that and
then it became just second nature it was
very funny when i when michael reeves
and i were
outlining the
the sulu story the star trek story that
we we did with george takei
we were both old hands michael was the
one writer who got me into television at
one point we're outlining the steps and
jotting it down and then about
two-thirds of the way through we just
looked at each other and michael said
you got this right and i said yeah and
then so we didn't outline the rest of it
we both knew where it went and then we
just wrote it
and uh but again you have to be a really
old hand to know how to do that stuff
but um
but outlines are great because then you
know well rod used to say rod certainly
you say
that if he knew the ending he could
write a script but if but he said i've
got so many stories where it's a
beginning and a middle and
no end and he said i can't write those
because i don't know where they go i
don't know how they resolve
and so
outlining rigorously outlining means you
know the beginning the middle and the
end
and uh because you do not want to get
lost in the middle you know and or at
the beginning or anywhere
because a story
has to satisfy the viewer it has to come
to an end where you go okay well that
was worth my time
and and so outlining is very important
it's not
i've you know again if you come up with
a better idea while you're writing
okay if but you have to know that it is
a better idea you can't think oh well
that didn't pay off if it doesn't work
don't do it it's better to follow an
outline
that works rather than experiment
but um
but the more you write the stronger you
get at this stuff you know and um you
just learn you learn your craft and
craft is structure craft is outlining
because um you know
that's just how it works you know it's i
you know it's like i
i write short outlines i don't i don't i
would never write like a 30 or 40 page
outline
but like the most i would do for an
outline would be maybe
seven pages for an hour script um and
with novels
i
i'll jot notes i don't rigorously
outline for novels but i know the
structure i know where the story goes
and i know who does what um
but but there are writers who don't
outline who are still very very good and
succeed
but if you're just starting out i think
outlining is a really important tool i
would urge everyone to utilize it but
but at the end of the day
it's getting to the end of the story
and however you got there if it works it
doesn't really matter how you got there
outlines are just a tool
how would you teach story structure
to someone who needs help i would say
watch movies
that
you feel have a satisfactory ending
and break write down the write down the
scenes write down what happens write
down how the characters move through it
and what the story does and see why that
satisfies
why that works you know years ago i was
hired to do a pilot where one of the
characters was a gangster the sort of a
bad guy at the beginning but then he
helps these two kids and he turns out to
be a good guy and i thought well how how
did they do that trick how did like how
do you do a trick where you like
somebody even though they're a bad guy
at the beginning and so i watched
casablanca and i saw that everything
bogart says is cynical but everything he
does
is moral is ethical and his actions are
speaking louder than his words it was a
very simple trick and a very subtle one
but it worked like gangbusters it was
terrific and so that once i knew to do
that
that told me where i could go
and so you you know there's thousands of
tv shows and movies
don't don't try and invent stuff from
whole cloth
study structures that worked a structure
is like a machine it's like you know um
you don't i don't i always say don't
steal plots but study structure
because
there's stuff that works and stuff that
doesn't work and the more you deviate
from standard structure the better the
writing has to be so for instance
quentin tarantino can use very unusual
structures but the writing has to really
be solid
and
so that's just the way the way that
works
how do you write a scene
[Music]
you try
to have
every scene
have an emotional point
okay
uh you you try to avoid scenes that are
just exposition that's a trap that
people fall into where everyone's
talking just to explain twists in terms
of the story and they're boring scenes
come from character who's who needs what
who wants what who's longing for what
who's hiding what they're really feeling
who's not seeing
what's going on in their heart or in
their head you find the juice of the
scene usually
it's conflict
but not always
you find
something
i mean usually the way it works with an
audience is
the structure is familiar the details of
the story are fresh
so in other words
like if you go to a certain movie you
know okay this is most likely going to
have a happy ending okay but what the
characters say how they get there that's
where you can surprise an audience and
that's where you can engage them
and so so it might be a story
from your life or someone you know or
something you read or you know any
number of things i mean everything i
write
is a synthesis a combination of
everything and anything um for instance
i knew i wanted to do a scene in space
command that was in spanish because one
of our actors was was from venezuela and
he's very charming and very very good uh
victor manso and so when i did the bonus
episode during the pandemic
i said okay i'm going to write a scene
where he's calling his estranged father
to invite him to his wedding
and
and so i wrote the scene in english
and i originally wrote the role of the
father to be guillermo del toro i
reached out to guillermo and he wasn't
available at that point for various
personal reasons but
but guillermo had had certain elements
from his childhood that actually wove
into that
that scene and
and it was about the son introducing his
fiancee to the father and trying to get
the father to come to mars in that case
to attend the wedding and ultimately
they want the father to move in with
them and it's about
a father's disappointment in his son's
choices and then finally coming to
accept who his son is and see the
commonality between the two of them and
it's a lovely scene and i was really
glad to do it in spanish because i love
the idea of having different languages
in space command for instance mira
furlin and the actress who play her
daughter speak cerbeau
uh in when they talk to each other
and uh
but it's a great scene with the father
and the son and the fiance because you
stop
realizing it's in spanish you're so
engaged in the people and reading the
subtitles and so and i had victor
translated into spanish and every now
and then he'd say well it can't be this
exact thing but this will make sense uh
culturally and i said sure fine great
and uh
but i really love that scene because
there's an emotional truth in it
and uh you know so that's that's great
every now and then i'll write a scene
that's just for the gosh g whiz you know
a
rocket ship taking off or you know
something like that you know battle on
titan or whatever it's very funny
because we were shooting the battle on
titan where these synthetic humans
they're soldiers they're gunning down
these these freedom fighters who are
human and uh one of the extras didn't
show up so i said well i'll put on a
space suit i said but you have to you
have to disintegrate me
so i'm in the space when i get hit by a
laser blast and disintegrate with a
scream and it was great fun great fun
yeah bourbon was great at that too what
is it sonata
the piano player or daughter they come
she's right and then or no no sorry the
piano player mother and then the the
social worker daughter
and and you know it's you don't need
subtitles to
you know the
tension and the emotion well now we have
thanks to netflix we know that foreign
tv shows can be successful here and the
people will read subtitles and that's
fabulous i'm i'm i'm oh yeah i'm so glad
of that well i don't mind me reading
subtitles i absolutely love foreign
films but yeah it helps to read so yeah
it does yeah this comes in handy and not
just ramona cleary books
nothing against them yeah there you go i
like those um
we've heard that
and you said this the other day on your
livestream solid
we've heard that you say you don't come
up with story lines unless there's a
chance to utilize them
why is that well i might come up with an
idea but the ones that i really dig in
on and write the script um i'm writing
that to shoot it i'm writing it to make
it i'm not i'm not
you know writing it's not an exercise i
never write just for like the i was
gonna say the fun of it i do write for
the fun of it but i don't write
something that's just gonna be in a
drawer that's that's purposeless um
and and and also my heroes when i was a
kid like rod sterling like ray bradbury
they wrote books
and tv shows and movies they could do
all three and so i've always throughout
my career written books tv is my main
form tv is my main art form and my art
form of choice but i've always written
books i've always um
you know written screenplays as well and
so
uh
and the books were you know i'm really
proud of the books i've done you know
and the twilight zone companion the book
with guillermo green lighting yourself
the magic time trilogy of novels they've
all i'm really glad i got to do them
they were
well worth doing
well what if someone says well i don't
i'm not there yet i don't have anyone to
to pitch to or i haven't assembled my
team or we can crowdfund and make this
um
what's your advice to that i mean so
they
should they still be writing just to
utilize them not just to sit in a drawer
you have to learn your your craft you
know you have to know how to tell a
story and you need to get feedback so
that you know if something works or
doesn't work but on the other hand if
you're shooting you learn very quickly
when you're shooting
if something works because if the actors
can't deliver it or you know i really
encourage people to
shoot what they've written at least to
see how it works when actors are saying
it i mean you you get a wealth of
knowledge from making it because the
script again is
is such a quiet object you know whereas
if if you make a short or a feature that
can start getting attention that can
start get and and if it doesn't work
you say oh those characters don't sound
realistic i have to work harder on my
dialogue or or um whoa this this scene
was really boring there was really
nothing happening there you know it's
things will become incredibly clear when
you shoot them and uh and that's again
where television is such a great
learning ground because when everything
you write gets made you very quickly
learn what an actor can say and what
they can't and uh and you know you you
it's a very fast learning curve and i'm
very grateful for that
and uh but
i would say to anyone
be bold don't be you know i was gonna
say don't be afraid you can be afraid
but there's a there's a saying that i
have in my wallet which is the bolder i
am the better things go
and that's so true
you know if you if you fall on your face
you'll get up again you know i people
say well life is like a river and it
takes you where you're meant to go i say
i say to people if you fell in a real
river you wouldn't say that you'd swim
like hell for the shore you know it's
like
you know don't don't just let let things
carry you along figure out what you want
and and but really go for it you know
it's like failure is not
a terrible thing they don't take you off
to writer's jail you know it's they
if you fail get better it's a process
and and
and also by the way
uh you know sometimes what you write
some people will like it some people
won't but if they really like it if you
polarize people where some people really
love it and some people really hate it
that's not bad i mean look at the work
of david lynch you know you don't have
to please everyone you just have to
please someone and the first person you
have to please is yourself
and the way you please yourself is by
saying i got that right that came out
well that was that was great
and um
you know so so
the lovely thing is that it used to be
that you had to come here to hollywood
to make dreams come true and now you can
make them come true anywhere if you're
in east mckeesport pennsylvania or or
kuala lumpur you can still we've all got
phones we've all got video cameras we've
all got the internet it's make use of
what's at hand you're in the 21st
century for god's sake you know you
thank god
but
don't waste the opportunity you could
make it you can make a short film this
week you know don't wait
don't wait act ray bradbury had a
wonderful sign over his typewriter that
i now have over my computer that says
don't think
act
and that's so true it's what it actually
is don't think do
and it's like yeah right on yes
absolutely
what was the most polarizing david lynch
work
while at heart
doom probably doing okay
well no but blue velvet i mean i mean
his
one of my favorite david lynch phrases
elaine and i went to see mulholland
and at the end of that it was a
mulholland drive it's whichever one he
directed mall in the driver i think and
at the end of the movie
you know the screen goes to black and
there's that moment
where everyone in the audience is just
sitting in the darkness before the house
lights come up and someone yelled out
what the [ __ ] was that
and so but i understood what the story
was so in the lobby i started telling i
was surrounded by a crowd of people from
the from the audience telling them what
the movie had been about what it was
because they had totally lost they had
no comprehension and then they said okay
now we get it but uh but again it's fine
because the thing about david lynch is
he's following his aesthetic purpose he
is telling stories he wants to tell that
only he can tell
great you know great
if you only had three rules in which to
guide your screenplay
what writing rules would those be
make sure
make sure that all the characters are
distinctive from each other and have
their own distinctive way of speaking
and
know what
they care about know what they want
know them write them as as people not as
um generic cab driver generic and
whatever anything um
tell a story
that pays off
in a meaningful way and not just for the
main character but try and have it pay
off in an emotionally satisfying way for
a variety of your characters
um
and um and have something fresh in it
fresh and fresh and meaningful
so that it isn't something you've seen a
million times i'm not here to write
stories i've seen a million times i'm
here to write stories i haven't seen a
million times
and
and that doesn't mean it can't be
inspired by the tradition i write in and
it's fun like for instance in space
command all the space command personnel
are named after famous science fiction
writers i grew up reading so there's
symac and sturgeon and bradbury and you
know le guin and and so forth and that's
very fun and the funny thing was at one
point i had a character named murray
leinster after science fiction writer
from the 50s and uh and i cast victor
manso who's latino and i thought well he
doesn't look like a marie leinster so
then i had to think of a science fiction
or fantasy writer a latino one and
finally i remembered jorge louis borges
who's a great fantasist uh from
argentina and so i named the character
jorge borges and uh so that was fun that
was very fun so uh but i just you know i
but i would just make sure it has to be
original truthful the characters have to
be vivid and it has to has to take us to
an emotional place that's satisfying
those are the those are the big ones
and uh i mean a film can
have a lot of drawbacks for instance no
one script is going to be everything to
everybody you know you can't like for
instance you might want to write
something about transgender rights at
some point and maybe maybe you'll put in
a transgender character in one script or
maybe ultimately you want to write about
that in a big
way that that might be the the main
drive of your story but again i don't
ever write
message things you know you have to have
a story that's engaging elaine will
start with themes i rarely do i usually
start with a character or an actor that
i want to work with or
it can be on almost anything it can be
almost anything and uh but i always
arrive at the same place which is a
story that i want to tell
so just as there's the bechdel test
is there a message test so that we
as filmmakers okay yeah you know you
know that that that it's a message uh
film if when the lights come up
everyone's gone you know so
you know i mean
you know i mean rod rod certainly used
to be very cognizant a lot to say uh you
know politically and socially but he
knew that you had to create characters
that the
the people cared about like when burgess
meredith is the last man on earth you
care about him you're engaged by that
man
and uh and you feel sorry for him what
happens to him you know it's uh
i mean i don't know any really good
writers who who don't put the focus on
character in science fiction you know
whether it's deckard and blade runner or
whomever you know there's people that
you care about uh ripley and aliens i
mean great example uh you have to
there's there's so many films and tv
shows where you don't care about the
people and you don't and it's just
forgettable it's just forgettable so
it's uh
really important to to do that and uh
you know and and again i'm not here to
change everyone's opinion my goal is get
is to convince people to be
compassionate and to convince people to
be
that that the power of love
is important that we're
we are united
by our commonality far more than we're
divided by our
opinions
you know and so that's what i would urge
people to recognize you know and uh so
that's i mean my big message is
compassion and
that's a good message i think to have
why do we care about ellen ripley
we hear about ripley because she's
she
well first of all in aliens she cares
about someone other than herself she's
trying to save that little girl even if
she dies she's willing to sacrifice
herself but also she's the smartest
person in that movie she's the most
competent person in that movie that
story is about her where she starts
traumatized and step by step by step to
save other people she has to take
control and command she knows what she's
doing and the fact and and again it's a
great marriage between character and
actress because corny weaver is able to
play a powerful woman where she's no
less feminine she's just competent and
and you believe every single thing she
does in that movie it's terrific it's
one of my favorite films it's a great
film
how was she received how was that
character received at that time well
it's very funny when alien came out you
know originally uh ripley was a male
character and they changed through a
female character and
and i thought it was great but my
brother jim my brothers grew up in
orange county i grew up in l.a when my
parents divorced when i was three and my
brother jim said oh man that woman she
was such a [ __ ] he was like so
traditional now i think he'd have a
different opinion he was young back then
but it's like he was from a much more
conservative background it was like you
know so he was like um
riled up about having a woman character
that's strong but i thought it was just
great i loved it from the first
so and that was what 83 79 79 oh sorry
79 aliens was 70 was 86. but the fun
part was
um uh before the pandemic 2019 i heard
that there was a high school there was a
high school in east in
bergen new jersey and it was
the the art teacher and the english
teacher had an idea that instead of
doing like you know brigadoon or
oklahoma for their high school play they
would do alien the entire movie and they
built everything from scratch the alien
suit the the 15-foot space jockey the
space suits the chest burster everything
and they thought they'd just fly under
the radar that no one would hear about
it just the parents would come see it
but then of course it went viral so
ridley scott
put up some money and they were able to
put on another performance
and they were in the eye of the media
storm and so i flew to new jersey to
north bergen new jersey to spend the day
talking to the students so because i
knew they were going to get a lot of
promises from hollywood and i knew those
would all be
false probably and would fall flat and
their hearts would get broken and i want
to say here's how it works and if you
come to la i'm happy to to guide you and
you can all be members of my round table
wherever you are and so forth and so i
spent the day with them and then as a
surprise
uh sigourney weaver showed up and she
hung out with the kids and she
introduced the play and it was just
wonderful i actually posted the entire
play on mr sci-fi
and it's great when the chest burster
comes out and there's blood everywhere
it was wonderful and and i said to them
i said the kids
this is hollywood what you're doing
right here is hollywood hollywood is
wherever you're creating something
that has meaning something that you gave
it your really best effort
and uh and it was i'm so glad i went it
was a wonderful experience that's great
i'll have to check it out yeah we'll put
a link below this video it's really fun
awesome well people can watch you know
the first hour of space command they can
watch the bonus episode they can watch
that they can watch my just sulu star
trek episode all on mr sci-fi sure are
you an lane yeah yeah just it's super
fun
yeah it's enjoyable and then we can see
your dogs too i love the fact that i get
to have my own network i mean
i wasn't planning that i just had lunch
with glenn mizera who was a friend of
mine who was the show runner on walking
dead and we were having lunch and he
said you know you know so much about
science fiction you should have your own
youtube channel and i thought
good idea and so
so i called it mr sci-fi and just
started it up i didn't do anything
really to promote it now as i said we've
had millions of hits and uh closing in
on 100 000 subscribers and it was just
like great because i can i can do
something short or something that takes
a lot more effort but um
you know it's it's really fun because
i'm so
so enthusiastic about science fiction
i've loved it since i was a kid and sulu
why should we care about sulu
well
when i was a kid watching star trek sulu
was my favorite character and because
george k was just so great and he was so
smart and so competent and loyal and
honorable and just wonderful and he
never got the great sulu episode and i
then found out
that there were a group of fans in
upstate new york making their own star
trek episodes and walter kanye who
played chekhov was flying up there to um
make an episode about his character and
dorothy fontana who story added the
original star trek had written that
script so icon and my friend michael
reeves back when they were going to
bring star trek back as a series in the
70s came up with this great sulu story
and so i contacted the guys in upstate
new york and i said listen michael and i
both wrote for star trek the next
generation the michael's an emmy winner
uh
would you be interested in doing this
episode and they said sure and i said
but i wanted director and they said fine
and um and so then i went to george and
i i typed up the outline of what the
story was going to be
and i said uh look you you never got the
great zulu episode you you deserved
and i said this is it and so he said i'm
in
and
michael and i wrote the script and it
took me six months to prep
and to a solid year we shot we shot it
in a matter of two weeks and then it was
solid year of editing and visual effects
had 700 visual effects shots and when we
were shooting i said to george next year
you and i will be on in japan
speaking to the world science fiction
convention and screening this episode
after which we'll answer questions and
you'll be answering in japanese because
he's fluent in japanese and i'll be
answering english and i said a year
after that will be nominated for the
hugo which is the top award in science
fiction and all of that happened oh wow
and uh so because it was i'm i'm proud
i'm very very proud of that episode and
it's every every i gave every bit of
everything i knew how to do in that to
write and direct and exactly produce
that and my contract was that no one
could touch a frame of it i had total um
directorial say and so it's exactly what
i wanted to be and as i say we cast
christina moses and she's phenomenal
every take was just gorgeous and i'm and
i've worked with her since she's in
space command now as well as being in
the middle million little things on abc
um but she and she'll be in magic time
and some of the other projects we're
doing so um
it's fun you build an ensemble of
friends who uh who you love to work with
how much of what you write is trying to
be original versus trying to give the
audience what they want well
i'm pleased when the audience gets value
from what i do
but that's not
why i'm doing it
i'm doing it because
i
have something i want to say
something i have experienced or
something i've observed that's
meaningful to me
and uh
it's so
and and there's just so many wonderful
pieces i mean
the lovely part about what i do because
of it's science fiction i get to create
a universe
and that's the thing that science
fiction brings that other genres don't
tend to if if you see a story set in the
modern day
it's just about those people it's about
that story but if you tell a really good
science fiction story the universe is a
separate
character in a way like for instance
blade runner you can do stories in the
blade runner universe you can do stories
in the star wars universe or star trek
universe and that's extremely
beguiling and i love that and it allows
you also to work with visual design and
because i was a painting sculpture and
graphic arts major i have a very strong
visual sense and i also know the history
of science fiction design i mean i think
it's incredibly cool and unexpected that
we have big silver spaceships now thanks
thanks to elon musk they look exactly
like the ones i saw in when worlds
collide or on the
book covers from my childhood and that's
just a thrill
um i love bringing a science fiction
reality to the screen it's um it just
you saw so many of my of my skills and
enthusiasms
do you think you'll be going up to space
in one of the various uh no carriers
okay let's see what happens
there's a few to choose from it's not
something that
i'm eager to do but it's not something i
wouldn't mind doing either
but i do know i personally know
astronauts and
scientists at nasa and jpl and all that
stuff is really exciting so
there's a member of our roundtable who's
a science fiction writer and his day job
is he drives the mars rover oh that's a
cool thing he has two watches one is on
earth time and one is on mars time which
is just super cool yeah sorry i'm late i
was you know right yeah i said a crater
oh wait
yeah wrong watch but yeah it's very fun
how do you build a character from
scratch
well it can come from a lot of places
uh idea what i do is i keep a list of
people that i've known in my life and
actors that i love all of whom are very
distinctive and have different ways of
talking
and every time i write a script i cast
it with people who are very distinctive
in my mind in some cases it's actors i'm
gonna
be working with so for doug jones and
bob picardo and mira furlin
and bill mummy i wrote those roles for
them for space command
but in some cases it might be an actor
that i'm not going to get like for
instance i wrote a script called
fugitive space and the template i used
for the lead was ed harris in the abyss
because it was a great character and a
great voice like it seemed very clearly
in my mind so i knew that ed harris
wasn't going to play that role he's too
old for that role now for one thing but
but it made the character very real very
alive to me and
so you just make sure that nobody is
just flat nobody's just there for
exposition
you never i don't tend to describe the
physicality of a character because often
you might have something in mind but
there might be an actor who doesn't look
a thing like that who's great
and you don't want to limit it and um
and i also very much want diversity in
my in my cast asian black different
countries
as
more the better you know and uh so
that's also part of the part of the
design i cast a lot of actors from
restaurants i eat at the waiters are all
the waiters and waitresses are all
actors and actresses and i'll if i find
someone who's good or who intrigues me
i'll say send me your reel and i'll i'll
cast them yeah i've done that a lot
that's great i like that yeah and also
too you can see how on they are yes
there was there's a restaurant called
granville in the valley and there was a
young actor who looked exactly like he
could be the son
of ethan mcdowell who plays jack kemmer
the lead in space command and he was an
actor and i uh and i cast him he's he's
in the bonus episode and he's great he
does a great job so i'm going to he'll
be in more episodes coming up
what mistakes do new writers make in
writing characters
new writers make a lot of mistakes in
writing characters usually the biggest
mistake is they're just flat they all
sound alike and they just are saying
exactly what they're thinking in real
life people don't say what they're
thinking generally
they might say what they're thinking
directly in an argument but often not
not even then
so
you want to think about how people
really talk and also remember that a
script is not
a representation of real life it's like
a 120 page haiku
and it's so it's it's an it's an
illusion of reality but it isn't reality
and so often the lines have to be a lot
briefer and a lot punchier um
but i always like to have characters who
talk differently from each other who are
very different in their outlooks their
world view
um
also
a mistake many writers make not just in
the beginning of the career their
careers but throughout is that it's
about the plot
and the characters are just serving the
plot
and that's not not a good idea you want
the plot
to be servicing the characters in other
words
for instance aliens has a wonderful plot
but ripley is at the core she's the
heart of that movie and if that movie
were about people you didn't care about
that and that movie also by the way
introduces a wide variety of characters
incredibly well so if you look at when
they all wake up from the sleep pods and
you see you meet all of those characters
they're very different from each other
and they have their own take and they're
very
you get who they are really quickly and
there's a lot of them and so studying
that just saying okay how did that work
and uh
it works like a charm it's great it's
great and if you said so so because
ripley was not a flat character but if
some things have been slightly well if
if she were a flat character you
wouldn't care about that movie it would
just how many movies are based on aliens
were they where they're like big science
fiction movies and because the
characters are forgettable the movie is
forgettable you you don't you don't love
movies because of the plots generally
you love movies because of the
characters
and uh you know and and i think a lot of
films are too clever for their own good
because they're they're just twisting
and turning the plot in violation of the
character and you never want to do that
because the moment the audience
distances from the character you've lost
them
and uh and you know i don't i don't like
puzzle boxes uh as as a structure i like
i mean you can have mystery you can have
revelations all of that that's fine but
i like to have characters who don't
you don't lose the characters because of
what the plot is doing you know and uh
so that's yeah and you don't throw them
away either you you respect your
characters that doesn't mean they can't
die they can but uh
but you give what they do meaning you
know you never just
you know you never treat anyone as
disposable and in my opinion
and so with the dialogue knowing that
it's going to be distinct for each
character you think a lot of new writers
start out thinking okay i'm going to do
sort of an aaron sorkinisk sort of you
know very talky it's witty it's well
also that's another mistake that
beginning writers make which is they're
they're they're talking talking talking
and talking
like get in and get out you know it's
like make your point
and then
on to the next scene don't belabor it
you know so they they're they're much
too wordy and also yeah imitating
quentin tarantino imitating aaron sirkin
try not to you know i i mean you know
sterling said when he started out he
everything he wrote was bad hemingway
and he said everything began it was hot
you know so you know and that's
forgivable in young people but again you
have to find your own voice you have to
find and the way to find your own voice
is what do i care about what do i know
about
what do i alone know what you know and
that it doesn't mean you can't write
things that are different from what
you've actually lived but what do you
know about and what do you care about
what gets you riled up and what's where
do you live emotionally and find and and
you know and then when and and if you
hear someone say something just in their
your your day i always carry a little
notepad with me and i jot things down
because if someone says a line that's
like wow that's great you know it's like
i'll you know i'll utilize that you know
and uh and try not to rip off dialogue
from other movies because god it's so so
many people rip off lines from aliens
it's like oh please don't and uh you
know so
that's part of it um
and and and don't bore if if something's
boring to you on the page it'll be
boring to everybody so
keep working on it until it works
and sometimes the scene doesn't work and
the only way to make it work is to get
rid of it and so be willing to do that
um it was funny i was giving notes to
someone uh last week and they were
saying well does this character work i
read their script and gave them notes
and there was a script that had been
developed at big companies and uh he
said there's this character work i said
no lose them they don't work and i said
and they're saying what about this
sequence saying no it doesn't work and i
said here's what your story is about
emotionally it's about a father and a
son and son doesn't think his father
loved him but in reality his father did
love him and shielded him and sacrificed
his own life but the son doesn't know
that and ultimately
our the son is willing to to do that for
his own daughter but the father's spirit
saves them you know this father comes
back as a spirit it's a fantasy film and
and once i said this is what your plot
is and everything else is distraction
and so don't
keep pulling it in this direction
pulling in the right direction follow
the emotional line
and uh because that'll work and so then
i just kind of took it
you know helped it along and again they
don't do they have to do my version of
their film no but they have to do a
version that works
and and if that if my version helps them
find their their path great
and uh because
many films don't know what they're
trying to
say or they have nothing to say you know
you know what what are most films about
most films are about two hours
you know so
you know it's like
know what you're trying to say and and
then remove the stuff that doesn't say
that
what's your favorite piece of dialogue
that you overheard personally that you
jotted in your little notebook yeah gosh
um
you know i
i don't remember and sorry about that
it's like
you know i
i remember one of my favorite lines that
i ever wrote it's a terrible line it's
terrible they're in future space which
is about um a future where we trade our
worst prisoners with
alien prisoners uh they
do they breathe methane we breathe
oxygen they're the prison that's holding
the humans is on a methane world so we
can't escape they can't escape our
prison here on earth because it's oxygen
they don't breathe oxygen and it's about
a
prison break that erupts at a um at the
handoff point a space station between
the two races and the aliens are like
eight foot tall jelly vertical jellyfish
they communicate via chromatophores
really fun and um and we're gonna be
doing that as a tv show but the
uh i had this guard who was like really
sadistic and at the end he saves one of
our characters and he dies and when he
dies he says i don't know why i did that
and and his boss the prison the head of
the the guard says
he was a prick but he had balls
it's such a stupid line
but it's like that's pretty good that's
funny yeah you know and again you know
you but again it has to be that
character who would say that line you
know and uh i think he was a dick but he
had balls whatever it is you know this
you know but again the reason that line
i like that line is because this is a
script that has rougher talking
characters you never have that line in
space command for instance which is much
more family show but fugitive space has
very rough language because it's
convicts and um
but it's about the industrial military
prison complex because ultimately two
prisoners one is a woman helicopter
pilot who's been framed for a wartime
massacre and the other is a former cop
who um
[Music]
killed his fellow officers because they
were going to murder a family he was a
dirty cop and that was the line he could
not cross but he killed them with
premeditation his brother officers and
so he's a trustee now in the prison but
a convict but they find out that the
earth government has struck a deal
with the aliens the aliens are fighting
a war that they're losing and so earth
has struck a deal with them that they
can invade earth empty out all the
ghettos and use all the poor people to
fight in their war
basically as slave soldiers and so our
heroes have to get back to earth and
warn everybody and and and build a
counter insurgency so
so it's about something meaningful to me
uh which is the the people the
underclass the people who anything can
be done to them because they don't quote
unquote count
and i write about that thematically a
lot the people
that people need to be given respect
people need to be seen as human and as
as equal to us in every way
and um so so it's going to be a very
interesting show but um
but i created the character who speaks
certain ways so that line works in that
in that context but the hero doesn't say
that i just have this tough prison had
you know the boss of the prison guard
started with charles derning i used
charles durning as a model for that guy
and even though charles derning is an
older actor who passed away but it's
very vivid in my head so that allows me
to write him so ah there you go but i've
written other lines you know but you
know it it it depends you know on any
given day
how does a screenwriter know that what
they've written is good
writers are often
misled in their own opinions of their
work they think the script is great when
it's really not
you need response from others and you
need to really listen
and not defend your work
now when you work in a mass medium and
you hear back from your fans or the show
is a success then you know
um and also as you get more and more
polished in your craft you often know
you know when something's at least
competent you know when you you know
what will work
but the funny thing is i often write
scripts and elaine is my uh the person i
get notes from and she often says this
needs to be better this needs to go
deeper it's like okay okay okay okay you
know it's like
and that's good that's good because if
something doesn't have the depth or the
or the emotional line i need to know
that um and and and frankly i wrote i
wrote one of this two-hour scripts of
space command
and we could absolutely shoot that draft
we absolutely could and it would more or
less work but it's not good enough so
we're going to scrap that entire draft
and start over again and i've actually
already done that and um
and there's characters we won't see that
they're in there and those characters
work but
but the story as a whole isn't as good
as we can make it so we're going to go
back to the drawing board and that's
fine it's harder work but but eventually
i may publish you know the lost worlds
of space command and include that script
so people can see where it started
because it's an entertaining read but um
you know i i
i need people in my life who tell me if
something's working or not but at some
point you draw the line you say okay
we're
we're rocking and rolling we're not
gonna because you can you can endlessly
rewrite and you there's a point where
that's again where television is good if
they're shooting on monday you gotta at
some point you gotta say well
you know we're done
and and you know roll camera so you make
it as good as you can but then remember
that when you're the writer producer
director
the editing phase is the final draft of
the script so in fact with space command
we're editing um finishing the first the
second uh episode with the visual visual
effects and everything and i realized
there was one scene that we needed to
add so we went back to the dailies we
called our actors we got some adr lines
we put together a scene that we never
shot
and there it is you know and we'll have
a visual effects
shot of this
ship landing and planting a
part of a wrecked ship to use as an
explosive on the big alien ship and
it'll work it'll and no one will know
that we never shot that scene
so it's i love the so it's pressed to
depress the digitation
magic you know so it's fun
what about the reverse though what if
someone says this is horrible and i know
this is crap and someone else reads it
and they're not there's no agenda for
this person and they go
actually this is really good no no this
is terrible this is terrible if the
check clears if the check clears i mean
if someone wants to buy a script of
yours it doesn't matter what you think
of it let them buy us you know uh it's
but but on the other end let's say
you've written something and you think
it's crap right and they love it
or someone loves it and encourages you
the way you know if something if a note
is correct is that everyone is saying
the same thing
so in other words if five people read it
and they all say you know i just hated
when he killed the dog then you better
rewrite that you know but on the other
hand if one person loves it and you
don't like it
well they don't have to i mean it's like
then you can say well let me let me see
if there's something of value here but
don't don't be slavish to their opinion
they could easily be wrong
you know so if they love it that's fine
if they're going to buy it let them but
but don't i mean
you might reread your script just with a
mind toward what maybe they're valuing
but don't don't trust it as holy writ
because they're probably wrong
and uh you know so but
at the en you know it's
you know but that's very rare that
someone says something that you think it
doesn't work and other people say it
does that's very rare that's what i was
wondering you know it's yeah usually you
think it's great and other people think
it sucks
yeah um
what a reality check how how delusional
writers yeah but but but there's always
going to be people who aren't on your
wavelength so for instance if i'm doing
science fiction and someone doesn't q
into what i'm doing because they're not
a science fiction fan there's no right
or wrong to that it's just they are not
their head doesn't live where my head
lives you know and that's fine
but they're not going to be my audience
they're not i don't need to convince
them i don't need to rewrite you know
you have to be very careful of bad notes
notes that wreck your script and you
don't you that's where you really want
to make sure that the people who are
giving you notes
understand what you're trying to do
and can make it better but not throw it
out and like if they say put a bank
robbery in it when it's you know a love
story or something it's like what you
know and that happens a lot so i that's
one reason why i'm not that big a fan of
writing groups unless it's professional
writers because you can just writers
groups that's why for instance my round
table is not a writer's group because i
don't want people giving each other
notes and tearing each other apart and
falling into cat fights and gunfire and
whatever you know it's like no it's like
you know professional writers generally
will know if something's working or not
they'll just be able to say well okay
here's this
another thing that's fun is even in
drama it's good to have comedy humor
jokes but not at the expense of
character or plot
so if you for instance if you look at
aliens bill paxton is the one who's
given all the jokes basically but
and they all land but that's because
that's a part of his personality it
doesn't take away from the fact they're
afraid that there's monsters coming
after him that is never
he's never laughing at that
he's nervous and his coping mechanisms
make jokes
and so that's and he's great bill
paxton's just great in that movie you
know so but uh
but yeah i mean
a lot of people
make mistakes
you just have to be willing to grow and
to learn
you just have to be willing to hear
people but not be slavish to them
you have to
decide that no matter what you're not
going to quit
and that doesn't mean you make crap
it means that whatever it takes
you're going to learn
what you need to learn you're going to
partner with who you need to partner
with
and no matter what the world does you're
going to get to the finish line
that's all it is
if you take responsibility and if you
take power and if you decide that the
one person who will be responsible for
your success is you
then
then then you can't be stopped there's
no way to stop you it's a it's you're on
your path
um
and it's great it's a great thing to
wake up
with the knowledge that you're going to
create something wonderful
and the world will see it
and
you're not a puppet dancing to someone
else's strings you know you're not
you're not uh
you're not enthralled to anyone other
than your creative vision
you know it's it's it's a great feeling
you know i think uh
the fact that i mean i came out of the
subway in london the tube before the
pandemic and i was going to a pitch
meeting with the bbc elaine and i
and someone on the street said space
command mr sci-fi
great that's so great and i was walking
my dogs uh recently and there was this
russian family we live in a russian
neighborhood russian family walking
across the street sort of laterally
these these
refrigerator-shaped people and the man
saw me with my dogs he said mr sci-fi i
love your commentaries particularly star
trek discovery
thank you
i mean it's wonderful i mean how could
you not love that life you know it's
it's great so yeah so it's um
the one thing that makes it all
worthwhile
is that when you do it right when you've
written a script and it's gotten made
and it's gone out to the world and what
you wanted to say is what you said and
people really valued it
it stands the test of time
it lasts decade after decade maybe
hundreds of years
and
it's you know that you've done something
worth doing
it's it's a great feeling
you know um
you're not you're not just kind of
punching a time clock
and the lovely part is
that you can work a day job and still do
your art
or you can make a living from your art
either path is is honorable
and either path gets your gets your work
out to the world and that's what really
matters